Wir müssen uns heute auf keinen Fall Sorgen machen, denn das hat schon längst begonnen. Wenn ihr wüsstet, was wir hier alles für euch tun auf dem nächsten Brücker. Das Radio bei Fritz. Der Computer Blue Moon. Mit dem Cars Computer Club, mit meiner Wenigkeit. Mein Name ist Johnny. Und mit einem interessanten Thema, das heute Wares. Heißt. Wunderbar, ein neuen Event aus England. England mit Ready or Not.
Und wir sind, glaube ich, ready, kann das sein? So, mal kurz Kontrolle hier, warte. Eins, zwei, drei. Das funktioniert gut. In der Mitte ist blöder, ne?
Was in der Mitte muss man mal anders machen, warte mal.
Ist jetzt besser?
Eins, zwei, drei, jetzt ist es ein bisschen besser.
Ne, nicht wirklich.
Wann noch mal?
Wann mal deins?
Ich bin auch da, hallo.
Komisch, das andere klingt irgendwie doof. Na, kriegen wir auch noch auf die Reihe hier im Laufe der Zeit. Es geht heute im Chaos Radio, im Computer Blue Moon hier bei Fritz um Wares mit Z hinten. Kann mal kurz jemand erklären, was das überhaupt sein soll? Ganz kurzen Übersicht.
Jetzt muss ich das wieder machen. Ich muss hier den ganzen Abend in diesem kaputten Mikrofon liegen. Also Wares, das ist geklaute Software. Das ist raubkopierte Software, das ist kommerzielle Software, die eigentlich Geld kosten soll, aber naja. Jetzt weiß ich, woran es liegt. Aber es ist nicht besser jetzt.
Wir müssen das andere Mikro nehmen.
Knyrischt. Genau. Was für ein Chaos.
Da denkt man wirklich mal, dass beim professionellen Radio Sondner, dann sieht es hier doch ganz anders aus.
Guck mal, der Stein hier, das klingt doch.
Ja, schönen guten Abend. Erst mal, ihr seid beim Chaos Radio, wo denn auch sonst? Merkt man gleich. Also, wir waren gerade bei Raubkopierter Software. Das ist Software, die kommerziell vertrieben wird und die Geld kosten soll. Es gibt Leute, die mögen den nicht bezahlen. Die besorgen die sich anders. Und wie die das machen, wie die das gemacht haben und wie die das in Zukunft machen werden, darüber wollen wir heute so ein bisschen berichten. Und da es nicht nur um Software geht, die man raubkopieren kann, sondern auch um andere Dinge, die Geldkosten im Internet zum Beispiel zu beschaffen sind, wie zum Beispiel Musik. Auch ein schwieriger Satz. Spielen wir heute die gesamte...
Vor allem, weißt du jetzt noch, wie du den angefangen hast?
Nee, spielt das irgendeine Rolle. Ich muss ja hier reden, nee, nee, nee, nee. Also, wir spielen die gesamte Musik heute aus dem Internet, nicht live. Haben wir vorher downgeloadet. Das heißt, wir spielen heute überhaupt keine Musik, die von irgendeiner Schallplatte kommt, die wir gekauft hätten, oder irgendeiner CD, oder irgendein...
Also, weder eine CD hier irgendwo, noch eine Platte aufliegen. Alles kommt aus dem Rechner, sind MPEG-Files. Dazu werden wir nachher noch viel mehr erzählen. Und sind alle probeweise ausgelehnt.
Wir wünschen dir natürlich nach der Sendung Support wieder.
Ja, ich schreib natürlich auch eine GEMA-Liste.
Und so weiter. Und ich denke, das sind schon dabei. Ich denke, das machen wir jetzt auch gleich erstmal. Du, jetzt drück doch mal bitte irgendwie ne Taste.
Da muss ja immer Musik drunter sein.
Nee, du musst das auch aufmachen. Achso, nein, ich muss den Regler aufmachen.
Dann versuchen wir das nochmal. Fangen wir mal an. Zu Ende glaub ich, ne? Ne doch nicht. The Beastie Boys, Sabotage! Herzlich willkommen beim Chaos Radio noch einmal. Und um das nochmal zu erklären mit der Musik, das geht natürlich hier darum, das zu demonstrieren. Natürlich führen wir hier unsere GEMA ab, ist völlig klar. Es geht darum, zu demonstrieren. Alle Songs, die ihr in dieser Sendung hört, kommen aus einem kleinen Schlepptop direkt in das Pult hier von Fritz. Und das ist alles aus dem Internet geholt. Und es ist einfach dazu da, um zu demonstrieren, dass es in der Musik auch Software ist und gerade in digitaler Form. Und da muss ich sagen, da bin ich so ein bisschen gemein, nachdem die Industrie sich so mit so vielen Lügen gesund gestoßen hat an dem Verkauf von CDs, finde ich, ist es jetzt nur... Also, sage ich jetzt mal so, ist es bei manchen Leuten recht und billig, wenn sie sich rechnen an der Industrie und eben diese Digitalisierung von Musik, dazu nutzen sie eben, ja, weltweit über Telefonleitungen auszutauschen. Wie lange braucht man um einen so einen Song aus dem Internet runterzuladen?
Na, das kommt auf die Bandbreite an, ne? Also normalerweise geht das fast eins zu eins. Also wenn man im Prinzip zwei B-Kanäle, ESDN hat, dann kriegt man das in Echtzeit raus. Dann könnte man auch gleich mithören. Und wenn man halt nur einen B-Kanal, also 64 Kilobit hat, das kommt natürlich dann immer auch die Verbindung zum N-Server an, wie breit man nicht der ist. Also mit 64 Kilobit braucht man dann eben doppelt so lange, um das in voller Qualität zu machen. Und das halbiert sich mit der Bandbreite, ist klar.
Gut, mehr zum Thema Sound, aber viel, viel später noch. Im Laufe dieser Sendung, erstmal geht es natürlich um die Software, die ihr alle kennt, nämlich Programme, Spiele, was weiß ich, und da übergebe ich jetzt mal wieder an den Chaos Computer Club. Wer ist denn überhaupt heute hier? Vielleicht mal wieder kurz vorstellen.
Ja, Andreas ist hier.
Tobias ist hier.
Na, Steini ist hier.
Und der Karo ist hier.
Heute mal also eine ganz neue Runde. Ich denke, wir fangen am besten damit an, wie das alles begann mit den Raubkopier, mit den Ver-s. Das war ja, wenn ich da richtig informiert bin, auf dem C64 die Mail-Tradings. Vielleicht kann da einer noch kurz was zu erwähnen.
Mail-Trading war schon fast noch vor meiner Zeit. Ich bin dazu gekommen, als das sozusagen gerade ad-appt und die Schuhkästen ausgetauscht wurden, wo dann 300 Diskette jeweils drin waren. Aber Mail-Trading war einfach so, dass man halt 5, 25 Zoll Diskette oder damals sogar noch 8 Zoll getauscht hat, indem man eine Diskette in den Umschlag gesteckt hat, Briefmarken drauf geklebt hat oder auch nicht. Und die dann in alle Welt verschickt hat. Und das war gerade in Europa populär, in Amerika ist diese Art von Trading ganz viel später erst entstanden. Oder wenn überhaupt. In Amerika gab es auch schon viel früher Modems und Akustikopplen und so was. Und vor allen Dingen waren sie billiger und telefonleiter. Und sie waren erlaubt.
Und sie waren nicht so teuer. Johnny, diese Musik nervt ein bisschen. Und die kommt jetzt auch nicht aus dem Internet.
Nee, aber ich finde, das klingt viel besser immer, wenn Musik drunter kommt.
Ja, ja, da kenne ich ganz andere Leute. Also ist egal.
Ey, wer ist denn hier Master aus Helmand? Okay, kann man jemand anrufen, das ist besser mit Musik oder ohne. Kann ich das sofort beweisen. Das ist völlig klar. Mit Musik drunter ist viel besser. Ist außerdem viel chaotischer. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hier ist...
Hi, wer ist denn da?
Ohne Musik.
Wo denn dran? Überhaupt nicht ohne Musik.
Das ist schon einst so ein Film.
Ich mach jetzt so lange, bis einer sagt.
Mit Musik.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Siehste? Wer macht seine eigene Musik?
Wir sind doch von euch. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Mit oder ohne Musik?
Danke, Alex.
Mit Musik ist viel cooler.
Gut, wo waren wir?
Wir waren bei Mail-Tradings. Das hatten wir glaube ich gerade so ein bisschen.
Ich denke, das reicht doch, weil das war eine sehr frühe Entwicklung sozusagen, womit das alles begann. Das waren vielleicht 200 Leute in ganz Europa, also wenn überhaupt, wenn das so hochkommt.
Als die Szene dann etwas größer wurde und auch in den Städten sich mehrere Leute kannten, die so etwas taten, da traf man sich dann auch regional und teilweise auch national bis dann international in Copyparties.
Ah, und auf Flohmarkten.
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Was ist wichtig, der Flohmarkt, auf dem man dann das Kettenboxen kaufen konnte.
Jaja, und alle möglichen Software tauschen und kaufen konnte. Die Copyparties, da ging es wohl eher darum, dass die Portokosten irgendwann zu groß wurden, man das dann lieber en bloc gemacht hat und sich das auch aussuchen konnte. Man hat also alles auf eine große Börse geschleppt, was man so hatte, samt seinem Rechner, hat das vorgeführt und hat dann getauscht und gehandelt wie auf dem Flohmarkt.
Und es wurde vor allen Dingen ja auch mehr. Man muss ja überlegen, es gab da nicht nur ein System, es kamen dann mehrere Systeme, es kamen dann Spiele auf einmal auf und man hatte viel mehr zu tauschen. Und deswegen war das natürlich klar, dass man wirklich Schuhkartons, man soll sich das bitte wirklich so vorstellen, das waren wirklich Schuhkartons.
Ja oder so, ich weiß noch, die fünften Viertelzoll Disketten, die kamen dann in so Archivboxen von Karteikarten mit Klapp und Schlüssel. Und war also wirklich so eine Ich hab meinen Schatz unterm Arm Geschichte. Gut, im nächsten Schritt, um das jetzt ein bisschen in der Einführung ein bisschen flotter durchzukriegen, waren wir dann, gab es dann die Möglichkeit, das über das Telefonnetz zu verteilen, über Modems, da hatten wir ja auch schon reichlich drüber geredet, das ist ja heute auch ganz modern. Damals waren die Modems noch nicht so der Brüller, da waren die irgendwie zwischen 300 baut und 2400 und das war also wirklich eine stundenlange Wartegeschichte, da ist das weltweite Warten heute wirklich direkt dagegen und vor allen Dingen waren die allermeisten ziemlich illegal. Ja hatten wir gerade in Amerika waren die erlaubt hier nicht oder zumindest nicht postzugelassen, muss man da glaube ich richtigerweise sagen. Aber, und das muss man auch sagen, damals waren die Programme auch noch nicht so groß. Das heißt, da hebt sich einiges gegenseitig wieder auf.
Das ist sowieso eine alte Frage, warum es früher möglich war, auf einem Rechner mit 512 Kilobyte System irgendwie Programme zu fahren, auch seine Briefe zu verfassen, auch ein bisschen rumzumalen und so. Aber das war wahrscheinlich ein völlig anderes Thema. Jedenfalls damals also brauchte man keine Megabyte übertragen. Oder zumindest, wenn man nicht die ganze Spielesammlung wollte, dann nicht.
Nö, das hat sich mit einigen Kilobyte dann auf der Idee legt.
Allerdings ist es ein paar Jahre später auch ganz schwer angestiegen, als man dann teilweise Software mit was auf über 30 Disketten war. Das ging dann schon die Nacht über und das hat dann schon ein bisschen länger gedauert. Wo sind wir denn eigentlich gar nicht? Sorry, wir waren jetzt beim C64, sind jetzt glaube ich ab dem Mailbox irgendwie dann beim Amiga so langsam.
Ja, eigentlich sind wir jetzt genau beim Amiga. Vorher war noch der, also vorm 64 war eigentlich der Apple II, das war auch so eine ganz große Geschichte. Jetzt sind wir beim Amiga, das war eigentlich auch die größte Szene und damit kam das eigentlich auch so richtig in Mode. Das werden all die Amiga-Fans, die uns zuhören, sicher wissen. Und die sollten und natürlich hernach auch Gelegenheit haben, hier anzurufen und von ihren Erfahrungen zu berichten. Aber jetzt spielen wir erstmal noch ein bisschen Musik aus dem Internet.
Cypher Sale, stimmt's?
Stimmt.
Kommen diese Quixte immer von dir? Dieses Pik?
Das ganz am Anfang, ja.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, auch.
Das ist irgendwie der Piepser vom PC-Durchsprecher sozusagen.
Control G sozusagen.
Aber wenn man tappt hier und das File existiert nicht und ich mein, das ist alles der selbe Rechner.
Wie alle anderen sind wir hier im Studio, bin auch ich, multitask-gäng, das heißt... Hast du gebootet, ne?
Endlich.
Ja genau, wir haben jetzt gerade den Fritz Studio Chat hochgefahren. Das heißt, wer einen Internetzugang hat und uns zuhört, kann sich mit anderen Zuhörern unterhalten im Internet jetzt. Nicht über IRC, da könnt ihr natürlich auch eure eigenen Kanäle aufmachen. Aber es gibt jetzt einen Fritz Studio Chat, genau. Und den findet ihr unter Netscape oder Microsoft Explorer. Oder was immer ihr zum Browsen benutzt, findet ihr unter www.fritz.de slash speakers, wie die Sprecher. Und da müsst ihr nur noch auf Studio Chat klicken. Und jetzt erwarte ich die ersten Leute, die hier reinkommen. Ich bin auch da und werde aber nicht viel Zeit haben, hier auch noch rumzuklickern wahrscheinlich. Aber es ist hauptsächlich für euch und ihr könnt Kommentare ablassen. Ich gucke ab und zu hier auf den Monitor und ja, dann können wir mal gucken, was ihr da so erzählt. Ihr könnt natürlich alles Mögliche verabreden, könnt eure FTP-Nummern hier austauschen oder so.
Genau, schicke Software rüberschieben, solche Sachen. Richtig, da war noch was. Das hier, das ist nämlich eigentlich verboten mit den Raubkopien im Internet. Und deswegen ist das auch ein Problem, dass man da nicht erwischt wird.
Ich habe die Musik vergessen. Ich war sehr leise, okay. Wo waren wir stehen geblieben?
Amiga waren wir glaube ich gerade. Das haben wir gerade beschrieben. Amiga war im Prinzip der große Start dieser Szene, die man vielleicht so ein bisschen vergleichen kann mit der Sprayer Szene. Also eine Szene, die auch ein bisschen was Verbotenes macht, aber auch nicht wirklich, weil sie haben ja nichts Böses im Schild, sondern wollen einfach die Welt nur ein bisschen schöner machen. Oder so irgendwas, man möge es mir verzeihen. Mich würde noch interessieren, Andreas, wie war das im Osten mit der Software? Ich kann mir vorstellen, da war es um einiges komplizierter, irgendwie an Software ranzukommen und die Programme auf den auch schwer zu beschaffenen Rechner zu kriegen. So und jetzt gerade speziell die kommerzielle Software, wie lief das im Osten?
Kompliziert kann man eigentlich nicht sagen, nur rar, also es war relativ einfach, wenn man dann einmal Leute gefunden hatte, die auch denselben Rechner hatten, einen Abgleich durchzuführen, das hast du, das hab ich und hinterher haben wir beide dasselbe. Es war auch relativ überschaubar, ich hatte da so ungefähr 50 bis 70 des Ketten mit Software und das war so mehr oder weniger das komplette Angebot, ich hatte einen PC damals und irgendwie gab das 10 Spiele und 4-5 Anwendungen, Toho Pascal war sehr beliebt, das wurde auch in Firmen eingesetzt und war deshalb leicht verfügbar. Was gab's dann noch? D-Base?
Frames kenn ich doch auch noch ganz früher.
Das gab das nicht.
Gab's eigentlich auch kommerzielle Software für die Ostcomputer?
Weiß ich nicht genau, also in der Regel wurde auf Copyright nicht viel geachtet, meines Wissens war es nicht mehr verboten, Programme zu kopieren. Und einige Ostcomputer waren ja DOS-kompatibel und auf denen lief dann kommerzielle Software, und zwar MS-DOS, das von Robotron gepatcht wurde zu SCP, aber es wurde eigentlich keine Software verkauft, es war nur ein sehr geringer Umfang. Der Hauptweg der Softwareverbreitung waren Copy-Parties.
Also auch da im Prinzip die Treffen, die geheimen Treffen, wie heute zu irgendwelchen.
Was hat denn das Kette damals gekostet?
20 Mark das Stück.
Ja, muss man nämlich auch mal dazu sagen. Wurden nicht hinterhergeschmissen, also wenn du sagst 50 bis 80 das Ketten, dann war das alleine schon an das Kettenwert von 3 Mhz, 12 Mhz, 12 Mhz, also tierisch viel Geld.
War nicht nur der Nennwert, man konnte natürlich auch auf anderen Wegen das Ketten besorgen.
Stimmt, die ließ man sich dann schicken aus dem Westen und so.
Ich tu dir hier den gefallen und du tust mir dafür den.
Obwohl wir gerade bei CopyParty sind, das war ja nicht so, dass du das Geheime treffst. Sondern das waren halt meistens nebenher neben Messen, CeBIT, Amiga-Messen, und dann wurden dann halt an bestimmte Wände, Termine, Orte, sonstige Sachen ran geschmiert, wo man sich dann halt traf, auf dem legendären Amiga-Stand in Halle 1, auf der CeBIT zum Beispiel, wo dann gegen Ende der Szene sozusagen die gesamte Wand dann am Ende des Tages, am Samstag, eingeschmiert war von oben bis unten mit irgendwelchen Copyparties, Messages, Mailboxnummern und sonstigen. Also es war ja nicht so, dass es geheim war, sondern es wurde schon mehr oder weniger offiziell angekündigt, aber es wurde nie irgendwas dagegen gemacht.
Das Gute da war ja auch, dass im Prinzip die Softwarehersteller, also die, die die Programme wirklich geschrieben haben, die kommerziellen, die waren natürlich an den Konkurrenzprodukten auch hoch interessiert, nicht nur aus Interesse, sondern eben auch, um sie wirklich zu benutzen, weil Software war ja damals auch tatsächlich noch nicht so weit verfügbar, sodass die also mitunter auf solchen Parties selbst zugegen waren und teilweise Entwickler die neuesten Produkte zur Verfügung gestellt haben. Sowas habe ich da auch teilweise beobachtet.
Ja, vor allen Dingen gab es Programme in der Szene, die so am Markt noch gar nicht erhältlich waren. Das waren dann natürlich so die Spitzen, wo man dann immer gesagt hat, dafür kriege ich eine ganze Menge, wenn ich dagegen kausche. Aber das war schon gang und gäbe, dass man wirklich so Programme, die vorher nicht erhältlich waren, sozusagen schon getradet hat.
Also so wie heute denn vielleicht irgendwelche Filme, die in den USA schon angelaufen sind.
Ja oder Musiken. Ein legendäres Beispiel ist ja YouTube, wo vor Veröffentlichung im Internet irgendwas auftauchte, wie Stücke.
Aber glaubst du nicht mal, dass das die Bands selber machen, da in dem Fall?
Das ist dann zu fragen, sicherlich. Ja, wer weiß das schon. Aber wie ist das bei der Software? Wer macht das bei der Software? Macht denn nicht das vielleicht auch die Firma, die abchecken will?
Das ist relativ sicherlich.
Das ist ja auch, aber da kommen wir auch denke ich später noch ein bisschen zu, wie das heute mit der Software ist und wie das in Zukunft auch sein wird, mit Demo-Versionen voll funktionstüchtig oder dass man dann bezahlen muss für kommerziellen Einsatz. Aber ich denke da sind wir noch gar nicht. Ich denke, weil wir auch schon fast wieder auf halb zu gehen, spielen wir noch eine Musik und nach den Nachrichten unterhalten wir uns dann ein bisschen über die aktuelle Szene, um das, was heute so eigentlich passiert in dieser Szene und wo man heute ganz aktuell so seine Software herkriegt, die man mal ausprobieren will oder einfach mal anschauen möchte oder einfach weil man eine gewisse Sammlerleidenschaft hat.
Chaos Radio bei Fritz, der Computerblumen, heute mit dem Thema Warez, was hauptsächlich erstmal raubkopierte Software ist. Und da Musik inzwischen auch Software ist, ist auch diese, die ihr hört hier die ganze Zeit, aus dem Internet gesaugt.
Ich denke mal, es wird nicht mehr lange dauern, dann kann man sich auch Filme aus dem Internet zogen.
Alles nur eine Frage der Bandbreite.
Oder Socken. Im Chat könnt ihr euch übrigens auch unterhalten. Natürlich könnt ihr eure eigenen IRC-Kanäle auch aufmachen. Aber der www-Chat hier bei Fritz ist einfach für die Leute, die mit IRC-Schwierigkeiten haben und die das noch nicht kennen. Und ich finde es übrigens, die Meckern hier Leute, das wäre zu langsam. Ich finde es überhaupt nicht langsam. Auf meinem Monitor hier geht das total fix. Jedes Mal, wenn einer was postet, ist es drauf.
Ihr habt wohl zu wenig Bandbreite, was?
Für alle, die irgendeinen www-Browser haben, unter www.fritz.de slash speakers könnt ihr mitreden und euch unterhalten. Bis jetzt wird allerdings nicht viel. Es geht hauptsächlich darum, dass man zu langsam ist und über die Namen wird gegrübelt. Der interessanteste bisher ist Birne definitiv. Da muss man ein langer Fritz-Hörer sein, um das zu verstehen. Ansonsten, mein Favorit, den ich auch gerne benutze, ist Icke. Auch mal sehr gerne genommen. Soviel erstmal zum Chat, unterhaltet euch da weiter. Ich lese mit, aber ich kann nicht viel zippen, denn die Chaos Jungs sitzen hier und wollen euch noch ein bisschen was über Warez erzählen.
Ach, richtig.
Ja, genau.
Ah, da muss ich drunter.
Macht das nicht. Wir waren in der Gegend weit angekommen. Das heißt, wir waren dabei festzustellen, wie macht man das denn heute? Und heute, da gibt es das Internet. Aha, und da wird alles toll und gut. Und da kriegt man alles, was man sucht. Denkt ihr, ja, ist teilweise auch so. Ist das so?
Bisschen ist das so. Also wenn man sich möget und an der richtigen Stelle sucht.
Ja, und wie macht man das jetzt? Nun besuchst du halt einfach eine geeignete Suchmaschine, sei es nun spezifiziert auf Wares oder sei es so das Standard wie Idlycos, HotBot, Yahoo, es fällt mir noch ein, Alter Vista. Und den richtigen Fallennamen weiß oder das richtige Produkt, was man sucht, findet man in 30% der Fälle sicherlich auch das, was man dann wirklich im Endeffekt braucht.
Das heißt, ich gehe jetzt auf Alter Vista und da sag ich so, Microsoft Word und dann...
Na ja, ich glaube, da wirst du eine immens hohe Fehlerquote haben, weil Microsoft Word wird noch in mehreren Dokumenten sicherlich so namentlich genannt. Insofern, du solltest das dann schon spezifizieren mit Wares, am besten gleich mit Z, dann bist du auch aus den richtigen Seiten. Weil, wenn dann nicht auch die Gegenpartei, also sprich die Software-Sucher und Ankläger, dann Berichte im Internet verfassen, werden sie das nicht mit Z, sondern mit S-Tonen, bis du gleich mit dem Z auf der richtigen Seite zum Beispiel bist.
Das heißt, man klickt dann die Seite an, und da kann man sich dann tausend... Aber was mich wundert, können das die Software-Hersteller nicht auch, und da dann einfach sagen, hey Moment mal...
Sicherlich, das Problem dabei ist aber, dass solche Software nicht dann auf Webseiten sozusagen abgelegt werden, sondern auf sowas wie öffentlichen FDP-Servern. Das sind also Rechner, die fehl konfiguriert sind, insofern, dass da jeder seine Sachen hinpacken kann, lagern kann, bis die Platte voll ist. Und dann erzählst du halt einfach anderen Leuten, guck mal da an der Adresse, da liegt dann das, was ich da abgelegt habe, und das verbreitet sich dann, dann fangen andere Leute da Sachen abzulegen, und so wird das immer größer, bis die Platte voll ist, oder der System-Administrator, der für diesen Rechner zuständig ist, das dann irgendwann mitbekommt.
Na ja, meistens bekommen die das ja wahrscheinlich tatsächlich mit, und freuen sich, was für ein Sperg von Software auf ihrem kleinen Server da auftaucht, und wissen natürlich von nichts, und pressen sich das heimlich auf CD, und verkaufen das dann irgendwo. Und da sind wir bei der nächsten Möglichkeit. Man kann natürlich raubkopierte CDs, Bootlegs sozusagen, auch kaufen. Ist das so, geht das, wo kommen die her?
Ja, haben wir vorhin schon. Ich denke mal, das traditionellste ist der Flohmarkt. Da stehen dann Leute mit ihren alten Computershots als Tarnung. Das kauft sowieso keiner. Dann sind da neue verpackte Kettenboxen mit Ketten drin, die man dann dazu verkauft. Dann lässt man sich halt rumkriegen und verkauft die Software so. Früher war es teilweise sogar so, dass die Leute dann nur noch mit einer Vitrine standen und das Kettenboxen und nichts mehr verkauft haben. Die haben sie dann ziemlich schnell von solchen Märkten runtergeholt. Aber heute ist es halt wirklich so, dass wir das in wenig karnen, um da nicht so aufzufallen.
Ich habe gehört, das kommt alles aus dem Ausblock.
Kau erstmal runter. Das kommt alles aus dem Ausblock. Hab ich gehört? Wir hatten einen Herrn dran, der sich darauf spezialisiert hat, solche Leute zu jagen. Den wollten wir eigentlich heute interviewen, den Herrn Grafenreuth. Das hat leider aus organisatorischen Gründen unsererseits nicht geklappt. Verplant und Chaos. Der hat mir aber am Telefon schon ein paar Storys erzählt, dass er gerade ein CD-Presswerk irgendwo an der Grenze zu Polen zugemacht hat, wo 1000 CDs mit Software pro Tag verkauft wurden. Oder besser gesagt gepresst und dann verschickt wurden. Also es muss die irgendwie geben und es muss jemand geben, der die auch kauft. Aber wo die heute nun einen Absatz finden, weiß ich nun auch nicht.
Vielleicht kann mir mal jemand erklären, mal abgesehen von so Sachen, die dann wirklich über FloMark laufen oder so. Ich kann ja auch auf bestimmten Websites zu dem Thema Warez, gibt es ja durchaus irgendwelche Freaks, die eine CD-Sammlung anbieten. Die kann ich dann bestellen, das ist eine PO-Box-Adresse in Staaten und der schickt mir dann die Brenta wahrscheinlich selber einfach bei sich zu Hause. Wie kann sich so jemand, vielleicht sollte man auch kurz mal auf die rechtliche Lage dieser ganzen Geschichte eingehen, aber wie kann jemand so was machen, so offensichtlich? Ich meine, im Netz, da kann jeder Zugriff haben, vom FBI bis zum Cop selber Schuld.
Also ich denke mal, der Hauptsächliche Schutz läuft dadurch, dass einfach so viel Internet da ist und so viele verschiedene Seiten, dass sie einfach in der Masse untergehen. Und es relativ wenige Leute gibt, die in der Strafverfolgung sich darauf spezialisiert haben, solche Leute zu finden und die dann vielleicht ein, zwei Monate so was verkaufen und dann wieder dicht machen und vielleicht in der Zeit gar nicht auffallen.
Und dann gibt es ja auch noch die Möglichkeit, dass die Server ständig wechselnde IP-Adressen haben.
Cool, aber das ist halt geringer Schutz, würde ich mal sagen. Also wir müssen da schon noch sagen, dass es auch Leute gibt, die da irgendwie nicht blauäugig in die Sache hineingehen, so sie wollen jetzt auch mal was machen. Die professionellen Leute sind eher so, dass sie das versuchen halt auszulagern, auf andere Leute, andere Server, dass sie wirklich gezielt im Netz suchen, wo sie sowas unterzubringen.
Da fällt mir ein, hatten wir nicht noch ein Interview zum Thema?
Hatten wir.
Ja, haben wir. Müssen wir jetzt irgendwie vorbereiten, ne? Da kommt nämlich gleich noch... Ja genau, da haben wir nämlich vorhin noch jemanden interviewt, der das eigentlich sehr genau wissen muss.
Ja, wir hatten den Herrn Mr. Rocks interviewt, der seines Zeichen in der Amiga-Szene damals einen der größten BBSen gefahren hat. Also sprich, er hat Modems betrieben und dahinter einen Rechner und hat riesige Datenmengen an illegaler Software sozusagen angeboten. Nein, und ihn haben wir einfach mal interviewt und ihm ein paar Fragen gestellt, wie es denn war, wie es dann ist, wie es wird.
Das können wir gleich mal hören. Vielleicht, wenn von euch jemand eine Einführung gibt, mal kurz in die rechtliche Grundlage. Also eine Software ist ja nichts, was man in der Hand halten kann. Natürlich den Datenträger in irgendeiner Form, aber eigentlich, wie der Name schon sagt, Software. Und die ist eigentlich nur urheberrechtlich geschützt, also nur in Anführungsstrichen. Da ist ein Copyright drauf. Kann jemand in ein paar Worten sagen, was das ist?
Das muss Andreas machen.
Andy ist nicht hier. Das ist jetzt ein echtes Problem. Er wüsste das genau.
Vielleicht sollte Andy einfach kurz mal anrufen und uns erklären, wie das funktioniert.
Ich kann das ja immer von der Musikseite beleuchten, weil ich das von der Musikseite weiß. Wenn ich einen Song schreibe und den rausbringe, ist der ja auch urheberrechtlich geschützt. Da geht es einfach um Gedankengut. Informationszeitalter sind ein paar Stichworte. Und auch vorher versuchte man schon, Gedankengut zu schützen, indem ich einfach meine Urheberrechte, nämlich wie das Wort schon sagt, das Recht, das ich dadurch erworben habe, dass das mein geistiges Gut ist, indem ich mir das schützen lasse. Ich sage, ich habe dieses Lied geschrieben. Und wenn das jemand einfach so nachmacht oder nachspielt, dann muss er an mich einen kleinen Betrag abtreten, weil ich das schließlich erfunden habe. Also es ist so etwas wie ein Patent eigentlich. Kann man sich auch vorstellen. Und genauso ist es natürlich bei einer Software auch. Ich darf diese Software für meinen eigenen Bedarf kopieren, aber man erwirbt bei einer Software eigentlich nicht das Programm selber, sondern man erwirbt eine Lizenz, um dieses Programm zu benutzen. Und die gilt meistens für eine Person, und für einen Rechner vor allen Dingen.
Und ja, weil man sagen muss, dass die rechtliche Lage bei Software Deutschland nicht wirklich unstrittig ist. Es ist so, dass ein Urheberrecht nur bei, ne, es waren glaube ich Patentrechte, nur bei schützenswerten Gedankengut wirklich gegriffen haben. Und die Lizenzabkommen, die Softwarefirmen mit dem Käufertreffen auch nicht immer hundertprozentig richtig sind.
Das heißt also im Prinzip ist es mitunter sehr zweifelhaft. Das Problem taucht zum Beispiel genau dann auf, wenn eine Software echt mangelhaft ist, Fehler enthält und so weiter. Das heißt, die Softwarefirmen gehen ja heute auch immer mehr dazu über, erstmal eine Demo-Version rauszubringen, die volle Funktionen hat, aber die kein Geld kostet, sodass man die ausprobieren kann. Und aus dem Rücklauf und den Beschwerden, die daraus resultieren, versuchen sie ihre Software zu verbessern und dann eben sie kommerziell einsetzbar zu machen. Das heißt, da versucht also die Softwareindustrie einen Synergieeffekt zu erzeugen zwischen Nutzer. Sie dann selbst zu Geld machen, das geben sie aber leider in keiner Weise an den Anwender weiter, diesen Vorteil, sondern benutzen sie, um noch mehr Geld zu verlangen für die Software und um noch mehr nutzlose Features anzubauen, nur weil irgendjemand mal sagte, das wäre toll und solche Dinge. Die Frage wäre, und die würden wir jetzt gerne auch an euch stellen, wenn ihr Software benutzt, die ihr nicht gekauft habt, die ihr aber hättet kaufen müssen, warum tut ihr das? Braucht ihr die wirklich? Sammelt ihr die nur oder wie macht ihr das oder wie habt ihr das gemacht? Das wäre unsere Frage an euch. Das würde uns jetzt mal echt interessieren.
Genau, und dazu gibt es eine Telefonnummer.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam, 7481 110.
Und vorher hören wir uns mal das Telefongespräch an mit einem, der es alles wissen muss.
Du bist Mr. Rox, bekannt in der Szene, in der Wörsszene. Und uns würde jetzt interessieren, wann bist du dazu gekommen, wie bist du dazu gekommen und was hast du da eigentlich gemacht?
Ja, also es ist ja schon eine Weile her, dass ich aktiv in der Szene war. Dazu gekommen bin ich eigentlich Anfang der 90er Jahre, kann man ja schon fast sagen, das ist ja schon eine Weile her, durch meinen Computer und dann später durch Freunde, Tauschen etc. von Programmen. Und dann später natürlich auch durch den Besitz eines Modems bin ich dazu gekommen, überhaupt so mit vielen Leuten in Kontakt zu kommen. Und dann später habe ich ja natürlich auch selber eine Mailbox gefahren.
Und die Intention, also was denkst du, warum war das für dich interessant oder spannend jetzt?
Na ja, es war sicherlich erst mal so ein, erst anfänglich, weil man natürlich einen neuen Programm interessiert. Musste immer das Neue haben, ausprobieren etc.
Jetzt aber nicht, weil du das bräuchtest oder sowas, weil du das gebraucht hättest, sondern weil das interessant war.
Nein, die Programme brauch dich nicht. Ich bin auch der Meinung, dass wenn man die Programme braucht, dann kauft man sie sich sowieso. Deswegen ist auch diese ganze Diskussion mit Raubkopierern und so ein bisschen daneben.
Also du denkst, dass im Prinzip du eigentlich nichts Böses tust oder getan hast, sondern dass im Prinzip, wer sich dafür interessiert, soll ich das angucken und wer es dann kommerziell wirklich einsetzt, soll das auch bezahlen.
Speziell Anwenderprogramme lassen sich, die sind ja auch, das liegt ja in der Natur der Sache, gar nicht bedient ohne Anleitung, ohne dass man da Support hat.
Denkst du, dass sich das verändert hat im Laufe der letzten Jahre? In der Kopierszene, sag ich mal.
Also glaube ich nicht. Das Einzige, wo es ein bisschen hingeht, ich sehe nicht mehr so viele Action-Spiele, die für Computer rauskommen, sondern wenn dann eher für die Spielkonsolen. Vielleicht doch aus diesem Grunde, oder halt auch der Altersgruppe entsprechend. Dass die Leute halt eher dann Spielkonsolen heute haben, die früher am Computer hängen, und der Computer eher was für Adventure-Freaks oder sowas ist. Vielleicht auch Spiele, die sich besser verkaufen lassen auf Computern, weil die nicht raubkopiert werden können, oder nicht so einfach. Weil man halt das Handbuch für Brauch zur Rollenspiele etc.
Nochmal vielleicht zurück zu dieser Szene. Kann man sich das so vorstellen, dass die Leute sich untereinander kennen, dass das so ein gewisses Gefühl auch untereinander war, sowas wie die Sprayer-Szene zum Beispiel? Oder ist man da ganz für sich?
Es ist schon so, dass man da so ein gewisses Gruppengefühl hat. Und da gibt es ja auch dann verschiedene Gruppen. Da hatten die sich ja Gruppen, die untereinander halt auch mehr oder weniger streng hierarchisch organisiert waren und halt auch bestimmte Aufgabenteilungen hatten.
Also dass man sich also die verschiedenen Jobs aufgeteilt hat, wer was zu besorgen hat oder wie...
Da gibt es halt Leute, die die Originale besorgen, Leute, die das Ganze organisieren, sage ich mal, die dann halt in Bobs spielen, natürlich auch in Wischjobs, dann Leute, die die Sachen knacken, also den Kopierschutz entfernen, sodass die überhaupt weitergegeben werden können. Oft sind ja halt Donkelschutz oder das Ketten einlegen und et cetera, originales Ketten. So was, dann halt Leute, die halt die Boards fahren und die verteilen, ja. Die die verteilen und halt auch Leute, die nur ein Modem besitzen oder mehrere Modems, neuerdings natürlich um die Sachen schnellstmöglich überall zu verteilen. Da gab es auch noch Leute, die halt dafür gesorgt haben, dass man umsonst telefonieren kann, um die Sachen halt in die USA nicht so einfach zu zanzurieren.
Das war also im Prinzip ein großer Klüngel. Aber die Intention jetzt allen Leuten, die das möchten, diese Software zur Verfügung zu stellen, das war jetzt eigentlich eher Sammlerleidenschaft und seht mal, was wir hier können, was wir haben oder gab es da sonst noch irgendeine Motivation dahinter?
Nein, also es gab eigentlich, viele Leute sagen natürlich, dass da Geld dahinter steckt, aber das Geld, was jetzt die Gruppe brauchte um Originale zum Beispiel zu kaufen oder manche Gruppen mussten auch ihre Cracker bezahlen, das war nur, um die ganze Maschinerie am Laufen zu halten. Dadurch muss halt irgendwie Geld angeschafft werden. Das war dann halt weder durch Verkauf der Software an Leute, die halt so ein regelrechtes Abo hatten, die dann ihre 300 Fketten im Monat zugeschickt bekamen oder von den Boards dann ohne Tauschratio Sachen runterladen durften. Das ging dann aber in die Gruppenkasse und wurde nicht unbedingt zur Bereicherung einzelner verwandt. Das war eigentlich nur, um den ganzen Spaß und Freude zu erhalten.
Ja, also im Prinzip die Fortführung der Sammelbildleidenschaft aus der Kindheit. Alles klar, wir danken dir für diesen Einblick in die Szene und einen schönen Abend noch.
Wer war das jetzt genau? Kannst du das noch mal sagen?
Das war jetzt Mr. Rocks. Der hat die legendäre Schizophrenia-VBS hier in Berlin gefahren. Das war teilweise bis zu acht oder bis zu zwölf Notes. Immer den größten Plattenplatz, die meisten Leitungen, die hottesten Weirs. Und die besten Infos sozusagen. Und ja, da ist eigentlich nicht mehr zu sagen. Die Leute, die ihn halt kannten, damals steht er sozusagen hoch im Kurs. Aber die BBS stand halt immer hoch im Kurs. Und deswegen haben wir ihn, glaube ich, auch ausgesucht, weil er so in Europa das bekannteste war.
Mal sehen, welcher Mister jetzt im Telefon ist. Hi, hier ist Chaosradio bei Fritz. Wer ist da? Stefan! Welche Erfahrungen hast du mit Warez oder mit Robkopien?
Na ja, ich habe ziemlich viele Spiele.
Was für ein Computer benutzt du?
Wie bitte?
Ja, ich lern mir öfter Spiele von Freunden aus, Kopie-Media auch, also Robkopien und so.
Und wie oft spielst du so in der Woche?
Eigentlich jeden Tag. Ich bin nur der Computerfreak.
Du kopierst dir die Spiele also nur irgendwie von Freunden, die sich das Original gekauft haben? Oder hast du auch ein Modem?
Modem besitze ich nicht, also ich lern mir die Blöds plus von Freunden aus und spiel die dann.
Du bist also in Wirklichkeit kein Computerfreak, sondern ein Spielefreak?
Was ist dein Lieblingsspiel?
Ein Lieblingsspiel? Ich spiele einen C1 FIFA Soccer 96. Das neue C97 läuft noch nicht bei mir. Wie viele Spiele hast du auf der Festplatte?
So 10 Spiele.
Dann nimmst du irgendwann neue Spiele und dann fliegt das Computer wieder runter?
Ich werde mir den Computer noch aufrüsten lassen, sodass ich jetzt noch die neueren Spiele spielen kann. Dann werde ich mir noch ein paar Spiele kaufen. Vielleicht auch wieder ausleihen.
Gut, ich danke dir erstmal.
Vielleicht sollte man den Ameisenhandel noch erwähnen, den sogenannten Schulhofhandel. Das ist relativ viel Software, langsamer als in der Wärtszene, aber von einem zum anderen kopiert werden. Irgendjemand kennt irgendjemanden, der hat Software, und der kennt wieder jemanden. Dann breitet sich das eigentlich von oben nach unten aus und läuft breit.
Was mich immer noch interessiert, braucht man denn all diese Software? Ist das, was man jetzt unbedingt haben muss? Ich benutze die Software, die ich nun wirklich brauche. Den Anagram gucke ich mir mal an.
Naja, wenn du Arma-Schüler bist und vielleicht von 20 Games dich eins wirklich packt, woher sollst du wissen, welches es ist? Und kaufen kannst du sie alle nicht.
An testen muss man alles erstmal. Vielleicht ist ja hier ein Arma-Schüler dran. Hi, wer ist denn da? Hallo, wer ist da? Ihr müsst super schnell sein, wir sind hier auch schnell. Na, dann nicht. So einfach geht das. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Wer ist denn da?
Ja, ich nenne mich mal Phil Kahn, okay? Ja, genau so ist es. Ich möchte mal so ein bisschen berichten, wie ich das mittlerweile erlebt habe mit der Kopierszene. In jungen Jahren hatte ich ja auch ein PC. Da ging das damals mit dem Atari los, so Mitte der 80er. Und damals ging ich ja auch noch zur Schule. Wie gesagt, da lief das natürlich nach dem Schneeballsystem. Und ja, jetzt kam halt vor ein paar Jahren irgendwann der PC bei mir auch auf den Tisch. Und dementsprechend auch das Modem. Und ich muss einfach sagen, wirklich das Internet ist ja nun absolut die größte Raubkopierstube der Welt. Also da kriegste Software, die du sonst irgendwie nie bekommen hättest. Daten, an die du niemals rangekommen wärst, werden dir jetzt offenbart. Und wenn du eine entsprechende Bandbreite hast, sprich einen Uni-Anschluss oder sowas, dann ist es auch kein Problem, sich mal 100, 150, 200 Megabyte runterzuziehen.
Du sitzt du wirklich abends in der Uni und siehst 200 Megabyte?
Na ja, ich meine, ich sitze nicht in der Uni, aber man kennt halt Leute, die lassen das laufen und dann krieg ich dann auch die entsprechenden Versen.
Die bringen dann mal ein Band mit?
Ich denke, du wirst dich da auch ein bisschen emittieren.
Nein, nein, wir machen so was nicht.
Bitte?
Wir machen so was nicht.
Überhaupt kein Stück.
Na ja, du wirst Leute kennen, die es machen.
Wir haben uns natürlich für diese Sendung vorbereitet. Ja, ja, natürlich.
Recherche heißt das.
Recherche.
Recherche, genau.
Sag mal, Schulkarn, hast du selber schon mal Software geschrieben?
Ja, früher mal so ein bisschen, noch vor PC-Zeiten, aber so im Laufe der aufgeblähten Betriebssysteme interessiert mich das eigentlich nicht mehr so, weil es wird mir einfach zu kompliziert und man hat doch im Endeffekt auch nicht mehr so die Zeit dazu.
Wie gehst du jetzt damit um mit der Software, die du dir mitbringen lässt? Die gibst du jetzt auch weiter und benutzt sie, aber interessiert dich nicht, dass da irgendjemand eigentlich echt für geschwitzt hat und sich was ausgedacht hat, damit du die gut benutzen kannst. Du sagst, nö, ist mir egal, ich nehme das jetzt kostenlos und benutze das einfach.
Naja, klammern wir jetzt mal Microsoft beispielsweise aus, dass ich eine persönliche Aversion gegen habe, aber wenn wir jetzt halt von der anderen regulären Software reden, ich meine vergleiche es doch bitte mal mit dem CD-Markt. Welches Schwein kümmert sich denn drum, wenn ich mir von irgendjemandem eine CD ausleihe und die mir auf Kassette kopiere oder so? Ja, ich habe Gemagebühren für die Kassette gezahlt. Dann lass uns doch am besten jetzt auch mal für writable CDs Gemagebühren zahlen und dann haben wir die Raubkopierszene legalisiert.
Aber du wirst lachen, die Musikbranche macht im Moment immens seit ungefähr drei Wochen sehr viel Stress sozusagen dagegen, dass du CD-Rohlinge anfertigst und dir die Sachen aus dem Internet ziehen kannst.
Ich weiß, dass die Musikgenostrie garantiert dafür sorgen wird, dass auf CD-Rohlinge mindestens auch Gemage zahlt wird, weil du legalisierst das damit ja nicht. Auch auf einer Platte steht hinten drauf, oder auf einer CD steht hinten drauf, dass man diese nicht kopieren darf.
Das ist nur die breite Theorie, aber jetzt guck dir doch mal die Praxis an. Ich meine, du hast doch sicherlich auch, ich will dich jetzt hier auch nicht kriminalisieren, aber natürlich nicht auch nur Original-CDs von deinem Lieblingsband zu Hause haben, sondern vielleicht auch mal die eine oder andere Kassettenkopie, die du dir aus der Videothek mal als CD ausgeliehen hast.
Klar, natürlich, deswegen ist ja auch die GEMA darauf, weil Leute das wissen und da gibt es ja dann auch irgendwie so einen komischen Umweg vom Copyright-Gesetz, dass das für dich persönlich so eine Art Backup oder so ist okay und keine Ahnung, also man weiß ja auch, die Leute sind ja auch nicht völlig bekloppt, die wissen ja, dass sie das überhaupt nicht verhindern können. Ich meine, außerdem bestätigen sie es ja dadurch, dass sie auf Leerkassetten eine GEMA-Gebühr verlangen.
Ja, vor allem wenn du dir im CD-Verleih gleich noch Leerkassetten kaufen kannst, das ist nun wohl der größte Blödsinn.
Aber es gab doch damals auch die Diskussion, dass man diese CD-Verleih-Läden auch noch versucht hat zu schließen.
Ja, ja, ich weiß. Ich traue da auch schon kräftig. Aber wir kommen da ein bisschen vom Thema ab, jetzt nochmal zurück zur Software. Ich meine, kannst du dir beispielsweise das neue Microsoft Office-Paket für 500 Mark leisten? Ich glaube auch nicht so aus den Ärmel.
Nee, natürlich nicht, aber ich würde das auch nicht benutzen.
Aber du und ich können uns das wahrscheinlich nicht mal leisten.
Nö, aber will ich auch nicht. Und das war meine Frage an dich, die ganze Software, die du da jetzt drauf kopierst, die würdest du ja wirklich niemals kaufen, auch wenn du sie...
Niemals kaufen können, ne?
Ja, aber würdest du es denn wollen, oder würdest du Microsoft Office für 50 Mark kaufen?
Na ja, also da muss man natürlich wieder rechnen. Microsoft Office ist eine CD, der Rohling kostet 12, 95, irgendwie so bei Karstadt. Betriebskosten, ja okay, so gerechnet würde ich für 50 Mark mir vielleicht holen. Wenn Microsoft Office wirklich eine effektive, bug-freie Software wäre. Na ja.
Ja, aber da sind wir doch beim Ende.
Ja, jetzt aber beispielsweise vielleicht mal eine andere Sache. Sagen wir mal, ich spiele auch mittlerweile sehr, sehr gerne. Command & Conquer müsste ja ein Begriff sein. Zwei CDs, pass auf meine Platte drauf. Aber mittlerweile überlege ich halt wirklich, ey, die Rare, die ist wirklich so gut, so genial. Davon kannst du ja eigentlich wirklich mal das Original kaufen. Und das organisiert ja im Laden nun nicht unbedingt unter dem Bereich unbezahlbar. Das ist wirklich bezahlbares Software. Und ich denke, wirklich so Sachen, die du wirklich super findest und die einen akzeptablen Preis haben, die kannst du auch durchaus kaufen. Und ich denke auch, ich werde mir auch diese Programme kaufen.
Ist das nicht sowieso so ein bisschen in der Frage der Fairness? Und ja, doch Fairness ist glaube ich das richtige Wort. Also ich sehe es zum Beispiel ganz pragmatisch so, wenn es eine teure Software gibt. Nehmen wir mal eine Software zum Videoschnitt. Da kann ich zuhause ein bisschen rumspielen und weiß ich nicht, das testet man eine Weile, dann stellt man fest, dass das Digitalisieren von Videos tierisch lange dauert und so und lässt es vielleicht nach einer Woche wieder sein. Hat aber mal mit dieser Software Erfahrung gesammelt. Wenn ich damit Geld verdiene, glaube ich, ist es auch kein Problem, mir die Software inklusive Anleitung und Update-Möglichkeiten und eventuellem Support zu kaufen. Und insofern ist es einfach eine Frage der Fairness.
Ja, natürlich ist es eine Frage der Fairness. Aber wie gesagt, wenn ich mir die Software hole, dann merke ich, irgendwie ist es doch nicht das Wahre. Dann ärgere ich mich nun doch ganz heftig, dass du da ein paar Hundert, weiß ich wie viel, tausend Mark drüber dafür ausgegeben hast. So eine Fehler habe ich einfach auch schon gemacht. Ich habe mir mal ein Spiel damals für mein Atari geholt. Und irgendwie war es dann doch so der letzte Dreck. Ich musste da unten das Ketten wechseln. Und außerdem ist es da unten abgestürzt. Und sowas frustriert natürlich unmaßgeblich, also riesig. Und da habe ich mir gesagt, ey, sowas machst du nie wieder. Und ich kann dir sagen, also ich hoffe, dass mein Anruf hier nicht so geroutet wird oder zurückverfolgt wird. Also wirklich das einzige Produkt, was ich von Microsoft legitim erworben habe, ist die MS-Mouse, weil die kann man nicht kopieren.
Und die ist wirklich ein gutes Produkt.
Aber die ist eigentlich wirklich nicht von Microsoft und wirklich ein gutes Produkt.
Ja, das kann natürlich sein. Ich habe auch schon eine Menge Clones gesehen, aber die von Microsoft, die ist auch nicht schlecht.
Also, aber ich fasse mal zusammen, du unterstützt eigentlich mehr die Shareware-Architektur, dass man die Software sich holt und dann guckt man sie an. Und wenn sie wirklich gut ist, dann bezahlt man sie auch.
Ja, nun gut, Shareware ist auch wieder so eine Sache. Ich meine, es ist verboten, urheberrechtlich Raubkopien ins Netz zu stellen, auch mal nach deutschen Recht gesehen. Wir wollen es hier ja gar nicht über internationale Reglementarien reden oder so. Aber es ist nicht verboten, Link mit Shareware ins Netz zu stellen. Auf der gleichen Seite ein Link mit den entsprechenden Seriennummern. Und also die Nummer, die du brauchst, um halt deine Shareware registrieren zu können, um sie zur Vollversion zu machen. Was ja die meisten Firmen auch machen, um da irgendwie Vertriebswege mit der Snail Mail irgendwie einzusparen. Und naja, ich meine, wenn du die Gelegenheit hast, sie lockt dich, gibt die Nummer ein, und dann bist du der registrierte User und kannst alle Funktionen dieses tollen Programms auf einmal nutzen. Oder du überlegst, dann gebe ich jetzt mal eine Kreditkartenummer ein und kriegst dann die Registrerennummer und zahl dann 50-60 Dollar dafür. Das verlockt natürlich auch ziemlich.
Gelegenheit macht Diebe meinst du? Bitte? Gelegenheit macht Diebe.
Ja natürlich macht Gelegenheit Diebe.
Da muss man sich halt wirklich überlegen, derjenige, der sich halt dahin gesetzt hat, die Sachen gerade bei Shareware halt programmiert hat, den sollte man eigentlich schon belohnen, wenn du das benutzt. Und ich sehe es ein, wenn du sagst, du willst die Microsoft-Produkte nicht kaufen, das geht ähnlich.
Aber man muss sie ja auch nicht benutzen.
Genau, angucken denke ich mal ist auch völlig legitim und wirklich das Shareware Prinzip halt auch auf kommerzielle Software zu übertragen denke ich mal.
Ich denke auch so was wie Shareware von unten. Wenn die Firmen das mit dem Vertriebskonzept einfach nicht begreifen, muss man ihnen das vormachen.
Aber meint er nicht, dass Softwarefirmen im Allgemeinen also ab einer gewissen Größe einfach schon genug Kohle machen. Also auch wirklich mit dem Verlust aus den Raubkopien verdienen aus und so schon eigentlich genug Geld.
Das ist ein Teufelskreis. Die Softwarefirmen sagen dann, sie müssen die Programmenteller machen, weil so viele Raubkopien von den Programmen exportieren.
Ich meine mal ehrlich, du meinst, die Software wird billiger, wenn jetzt alle Leute...
Nein, sicherlich nicht, aber das ist ein billiges Argument.
Ja genau, das ist doch ein altes Argument. Was ist denn widerlegt, dieses Argument? Die Firmen sagen immer, wenn nicht so viel Raub kopiert würden, wäre, war, will und so weiter. Dann wäre die Software billiger. Da gibt es noch ein anderes Argument, was zu widerlegen ist und auch leicht zu widerlegen ist, dass der Softwareindustrie so und so viele Milliarden Schaden entstehen durch Raub kopieren. Da können wir gleich auch nochmal drüber reden.
Das kann man doch gar nicht so sagen. Mal wieder Beispiel, Lieblingsbeispiel. Ich weiß, Microsoft Office. Gut, das Ding kostet 500 Mark. Jetzt registriert sich einer diese Version und gibt es an fünf Leute weiter, die sie an fünf Leute weitergeben. Hast du 25 plus einen Leute, die diese Version jetzt haben, weil der eine hat einen CD-Brenner oder so, oder fünf haben CD-Brenner, ist ja auch egal. Aber meinst du, wenn diese Leute jeweils 500 Mark an MS abdrücken müssten dafür, die würden das machen, die könnten sich die Software einfach nicht leisten und hätten sie dann doch nicht. Also dadurch würde Microsoft keinen Dollar mehr verdienen. Weil die Leute, die es dann registrieren würden, es einfach nicht registrieren könnten, weil sie das Kapital nicht dazu haben. Ja, ich denke mal auch. Und wirklich, ich sehe auch irgendwie bislang kein Problem, sich wirklich im Internet erstens Wares zu geschaffen und zweitens Wares ins Netz reinzustellen. Es gibt so viele Server im Netz, wo du umsonst Web Stays kriegst, was ich GeoCities, um jetzt so mal das Kleinte zu nennen, ich will ja auch keine Werbung für machen. Die sind auch nicht so die Tollen, da gibt es weitaus schönere Dinge. Man muss nicht mal hier so selbst drum kümmern, also geht hoch bis zum Free Web Space bis zu 100 Megabyte oder so, was wir da letztens gefunden haben. Ich sehe da eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem, sich da irgendwie neue Software zu besorgen. Und ich denke mal, das wird auch über lange Zeit einfach so bleiben. Weil, wie gesagt, du kannst das Netz nicht kontrollieren.
Paragraph Nummer 1.
Schokan, dank dir erst mal.
Darf ich noch einen grüßen?
Na klar, lass mich raten.
Ich grüße Commander Katana.
Dazu übrigens, weil natürlich jetzt viele Leute wahrscheinlich wissen, wo kriegt das denn alles und so, dazu war der Tipp von Schokan gerade wirklich, der einzige, den man dazu nennen kann, sich selber drum kümmern. Das ist alles nicht so schwer und macht Spaß und ist Teil des Spiels. Hören wir MPEGs? Hoffentlich. Im Chat, der einzige wahre Johnny ich bin, wäre, wenn ich den Chat abschalte.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich das machen soll. Wäre auch gemein.
Ja toll, Chatten ist toll, wenn sich alle auf einmal Johnny nennen.
Super.
Oder Chaosradio oder so.
Caro, was warst du eigentlich damals?
Trailer?
Gute Frage.
Ich glaube, ich habe als Grafiker sozusagen angefangen, gleich wirklich aus der vorhin schon angesprochenen Graffiti-Szene kam. Hab dann aber irgendwann die Faszination des Modems mitbekommen, weil ich, was habe ich damals getauscht? Ich habe mein Z80 gegen einen Discovery 2400 getauscht. Ja, der damit bleibt dann dabei sozusagen. Dann habe ich mir irgendwann mal vom Freund ein USR HST Modem ausgeliehen. Dann habe ich angefangen, mir Programme hin und her zu kopieren. Dann habe ich mir sogar angefangen, schon die erste Blue Box zu besorgen. Da war das gerade am Anfang aus der Schweiz. Dann wurde ich schon ein wenig zum Trader, was ich aber irgendwie versucht habe zu vermeiden. Aber das macht einfach süchtig. Ich habe schon nachgefragt vorhin, warum tut man das? Ich denke wirklich, da ist ein gewisser Teil Sucht dabei. Morgens mit der Pizza in der Hand von gestern Abend anzufangen, gucken, was kam heute Nacht oder während ich schliefe.
Vier Köpfe, die jetzt hier so grinsen, nicken, ja.
Man muss dazu unter 25 sein, wollte ich noch dazu sagen.
Unter 15.
Ah nein, nein, nein.
Man muss noch nicht darauf angewiesen sein, sein eigenes Geld zu verdienen.
Das ist richtig, ja. Noch zur Schule zu gehen, keine anderen Probleme zu haben, mal schwänzen zu können. Ich denke, das war wirklich der Suchtfaktor. Ich glaube, das ist so das, was die größte Motivation bei den Trailern ist. Die Sucht nach Anerkennung, nach der beste Trailer zu sein, immer die neuesten Weste haben. Man guckt sich das irgendwann gar nicht mehr an. Man muss sich das so vorstellen, man schiebt da pro Tag so um die 100 bis 200 Megabyte durch die Gegend. Jetzt bei PC-Gedämmnis mag das sicherlich noch mehr sein. Man packt das halt einfach gar nicht mehr aus. Sondern es wird halt nur noch runtergesaugt und woanders wieder abgeloadet und fertig.
Raumkopie zum Selbstzweck, zur Freizeitgestaltung.
Ja, genau, und irgendwie im Endeffekt bringt einem das nichts. Man wacht hinterher irgendwann auf und stellt fest, man hat die Pizza immer noch an der Hand, hat aber irgendwie keine Freunde mehr oder hat die Schule verpasst oder sonst irgendwas. Da gibt es auch reguläre Fälle, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ja, du hast ja jetzt doch geschafft auf einer Art, bist da ja wieder rausgekommen.
Ich denke, es haben sicherlich eine ganze Menge Leute geschafft, aber es gibt genauso Leute, die sind dann auf andere Bahnen, würde ich mal sagen, dann abgedriftet, weil man lernt schon Leute kennen, die einem nicht zuträglich sind. Also da fangen Leute dann an mit Teppichen auch zu handeln nebenbei oder... Ach nein, es gibt aber Leute, will ich so sagen.
Ja, ich habe damals, nachdem ich meinen Modem gekauft habe, nicht so richtig schnell den Einstieg in die Szene gefunden, erst als ich dann eine Box in der Gegend aufgetan hatte und den Leuten erklärt hätte, ich könnte halt auch cracken, weil das habe ich schon mal gemacht. Und dann war ich ruckzuck der Cracker der Group und hatte...
In welcher Gruppe?
Download TLI. Und ja, fand das eigentlich sehr lustig, weil ich musste nirgends ablohnen, ich hatte immer überall meine Software und Cracken war eigentlich auch ganz lustig.
Ich glaube so, das war sowieso das Downloaden, das Unlimited... Die Unlimited-Null-Radio, die war bei AmiExpress dann glaube ich so das beliebteste und das bestrebteste Ziel, das man dann hatte. Ja, wollen wir nicht noch einfach noch mal ein paar Namen von früher sagen, um die Sache vielleicht auch bei manchen Hörern noch ein bisschen anzukurbeln, die das hier anrufen? Ich darf mal anfangen.
Ja, die waren glaube ich auf Amiga und PC aktiv.
Die waren ab C64 aktiv. Die hießen früher TriStar war eine Gruppe, Red Sektor war eine Gruppe. Ja, aber wobei, das ist so eine Ausnahme für einen, das war dann nachher irgendwann mehr Demo-Gruppe als alles andere.
Na ja, Red Sektor war auf PC erst hauptsächlich eine Treller Gruppe. Sie haben relativ viele Cracks gebracht und auch immer relativ aktuelle Sachen. Also zu meinen Zeiten ungefähr 50% der Spiele.
Ja, und die besten Demos. Mega-Demo. Wollen wir vielleicht einfach mal ein paar Hörer fragen, in welchen Gruppen sie so waren und was sie damals gemacht haben? Was sie einfach darüber wussten. Weil ich denke mal als so genannter Insider kriegt man noch wenig mit, was so die Außenstehenden sagen. Man hört da ja immer nur so, ach da ja und alles klasse oder eben nicht. So alle Treller haben ein Ding an der Waffe. Wurde mich einfach mal interessieren. Was denkt ihr über die Leute, die sowas gemacht haben, machen, tun? Was wisst ihr darüber?
Ja, was wisst ihr darüber?
Welche von denen?
Bist du einer von denen? Hallo?
Hallo?
Ja, bist du einer von denen oder was weißt du darüber?
Naja, ich benutze die Software. Naja, zum Beispiel, früher waren ja die Namen wie zum Beispiel die TDD oder sowas. The Factors Detectors oder so ganz public. Die haben damals recht gute Spiele publiziert, aber finde ich heute nicht mehr so in dem Maße Namen wie TDD oder TSI oder sowas findet man einfach nicht mehr so. Und mittlerweile kriegt man mit, dass nicht mehr unter so Labels publiziert wird, sondern einfach jeder für sich kriegt. Und dann kommt dann so ein Name wie Maverick oder so.
Bist du denn da heute jetzt noch dabei oder bist du da ausgestiegen, als das irgendwie mit der Mailbox-Szene so ein bisschen dem Ende zu ging und alles aufs Internet sich verlegt hat?
Na, ich sag das mal so, aus dem Internet oder so ist das immer eine ziemlich teure Sache für unsere Gegend hier. Weil ich bin kein Student und damit muss ich mir das selbst leisten. Und per Telefon, wie vorhin schon jemand versucht hat anzudeuten, also in der Uni runterzuladen, ist das alles noch ganz lustig. Aber wenn man sich das dann zu Hause leisten muss...
Aber im Moment, die Trader sozusagen haben ja damals, bevor es Möglichkeiten zum Umsonsttelefonieren gab, auch bezahlt dafür zumindest...
Ja, haben das dann über BBS gemacht. Und darüber hat man sich das dann mit ein paar Kumpels oder so finanziert. Deshalb fand ich das vorhin ganz eigenartig, wie ihr sagte, man könnte da in eigenartige Kanäle abrutschen, die Schule vergessen, die Freunde vergessen.
Ach du, ich kenne da einfach ein paar Fälle, wo das einfach wirklich der Fall war. Die dann nichts anderes.
Das sind nur die Fälle, die für die Zeitung sind, oder?
Nö, also wenn ich nur mal auf Anheb überlege, sind das mindestens drei. Und wenn ich sicher noch mehr überlege, kenne ich sicherlich noch mehr Fälle.
Also ich meine, bei mir persönlich muss ich sagen, durch Raubkuppien oder so, ist das Ganze ganz lustig geworden.
Nee, wir haben ja da nicht über Raubkuppien so an sich geredet, sondern wir haben über die Leute geredet, die das dann professionell verbreiten, über die sogenannten Trader, zum Beispiel, weil ich wurde gefragt, was ich bin, ob ich Trader oder was ich denn war. Und es gab einfach auf der Trader-Seite wirklich bei den Leuten, die das verbreitet haben, einfach Fälle, die haben um sich herum eine ganze Menge nicht mitbekommen. So kamen wir da drauf. Und deswegen sagte ich, ich kenne da viel Gute.
Ja gut, jeder, der da richtig tief einsteigt, ist ja wohl auch in der Musikszene oder so. Also richtige DJs oder so, die kriegen wohl auch kaum noch mit, was um sich herum passiert.
Das habe ich hier 100.000 Mal gesehen. Johnny, was weißt du denn darüber?
Ich kriege gar nichts mit hier, ich bin hier am Schlafen.
Total abgestiegen, ja?
Nee, ich bin hier immer so hin und hergerissen, weil ich lasse mich ja so gerne provozieren.
Johnny streitet sich mit den Hörern im Internet.
Ich muss mich immer total zurückhalten, um das nicht zu tun.
Ja, morgen steht es in der Zeitung, er ist der Tote im Internet.
Ich habe ja zu dem ganzen Thema ganz wenig zu sagen. Ich bin ja Mac-Benutzer, da hätte ich eine Menge Tipps.
Mklinux installieren ist ein guter Tipp, stürz nicht ab.
Das ist auch möglich.
Fehler 11.
Deswegen höre ich euch einfach interessiert zu. Außerdem haben wir natürlich alles, was wir hier vorbereitet haben, aus reinen Recherchezwecken gemacht. Wir haben ein bisschen herumgeguckt, was es alles so gibt und waren überrascht.
Alles downgraded, ausprobiert und schnell Sicherheits-Scoping gemacht, damit wir Beweise haben.
Genau. Mich interessiert bei dieser ganzen Geschichte, dass der Schaden der Industrie, die man nicht wirklich kennt, die beim Betreiben eines BBS oder ähnlicher Systeme oder beim Handeln Midwares erwischt worden sind. Denn nach wie vor ist es illegal und man kann sehr hoch bestraft werden. Und was mit diesen Leuten passiert dann zum Beispiel, weil das klingt jetzt alles so super witzig und höh höh und ist ganz easy, aber so ein bisschen Vorsicht ist nach wie vor geboten, oder?
Ja, also ich persönlich kenne einen Fall, der auch über den allseits beliebten Herrn Gravenreuth in einer Falle gelaufen ist. Und zwar hat unser auch allseits beliebter Freund Kimbell in München eine BBS betrieben und hat dort das im Auftrag von Gravenreuth getan, der wiederum im Auftrag von Softwarefirmen diese BBS als Tarn-BBS angelegt hat und hat dort Call-In-Card...
Das sagt er jetzt nicht zu...
.hat dort auf jeden Fall Call-In-Card-Nummern verkauft und daraufhin ist Gravenreuth bei den Käufern der Call-In-Card-Nummern eingeritten und zwar indem er entsprechende Briefe an die Staatsanwaltschaften geschrieben hat, die dann Horstdurchsuchungen gemacht haben und dabei auch Robkopien beschlagnahmt haben.
Da kenne ich auch den einen oder anderen Fall. Aber wir haben ja noch einen Hörer dran. Hast du nicht da auch noch was?
Ich würde denken, man kann sich da entsprechend absichern, indem man die ganze Sache so verschlüsselt, dass das nur Leute lesen können, für dessen Augen man das bestimmt.
Das ist richtig.
Wie kriegst du das raus, wer die Leute sind? Also entweder du kennst die alle persönlich oder du glaubst es irgendjemandem?
Na gut, mit der Sache du glaubst es irgendjemandem fängt das schon an.
Und damit würde ich sagen, man muss die Leute mindestens einmal gesehen haben.
Und so zum Beispiel, was momentan ziemlich innen ist, sind so genannte User Parties oder so. Da kriegt man dann einfach mal hin und wieder irgendeinen Public Key zugesteckt und kann dann einfach per RSR-Codierung auf irgendwas drauf zugreifen.
Und woher weißt du dann, dass er derjenige, der dir diesen Key zugesteckt hat, nicht derjenige ist, der dich dann auch nachher anzeigt? Also es ist doch einfach Obscurity sozusagen. Security by Obscurity, du hast einfach keine Sicherheit.
Stimmt schon, aber irgendwie bin ich nicht der Meinung, dass so jemand vielleicht in so eine Insider-Party hineinkommt.
Klar, kein Problem. Jeder hat irgendwie mal angefangen, ohne dass er jemanden kannte. Man musste nur lange genug baggern, genug irgendwelche Leute nerven, bis man irgendwo mitgeschleppt wurde. Also das geht schon immer.
Ich denke, ein ganz interessantes Thema ist ja noch das anonyme Verbreiten der Software im Internet über Newsgroups zum Beispiel. Das ist ja ein Weg, Alt, Binary, Wares, IBM, PC zum Beispiel. Es gibt derzeit, wir hatten das in einer alten Sendung ja auch schon, von zig News-Server, die offen zugänglich sind. Und ganz viele davon führen eben auch diese Gruppen. Und das Problem dabei ist, das ist ein wenig mühsam, da sich die Software-Pakete zusammenzustellen. Das Problem ist dabei, ja.
Aber für den Provider ist es sicher, dass er es anbietet.
Wieso ist das sicher?
Na, wenn ich das irgendwie anonym anbiete, ohne dass ich darauf praktisch proche, dass mein Name da drin steht, also was sehe ich, dass ich der und der bin, wie vorhin, was sehe ich, die Snake oder so, irgend sowas, dann fällt das ja gar nicht auf. Weil dann bin ich einfach anonym und sage mir, ich verbreite das im Sinne der Shareware.
Das ist richtig, dann kriegst du aber auch... Das damalige Feeling kam ja dadurch auf, dass du eine Ratio sozusagen hast, sprich du hast eine Sache abgelotet, durftest dir dort downloaden. So kam ja sozusagen der Flair da hoch, sich hoch zu arbeiten, bis man genug downloaden konnte, dass man nicht sagen konnte, ich könnte prinzipiell 20, 30, 100 Gigabyte downloaden.
Ja, aber heute ist das ja nicht mehr so, oder nicht mehr wirklich. Heute gibt es das in den News, da wird das darüber gemacht, dass dann 77 Disketten einer Software ungenannten Namens da verbreitet wird. Jede Diskette nochmal gesplittet in drei ZIP-Files und die 78. Diskette, die man unbedingt braucht, die fehlt. Und die kriegst du dann irgendwie über einen anonymen Remailer zugeschickt, wenn du in diese Newsgruppe folgendes Produkt, und so funktioniert das ja heute, also die Anonymisierung über diese Dinge, die funktioniert heute da ja sehr viel besser.
MPEX oder Neuer Hörer? Danke.
Das Recht ist zu kopieren.
So ist das also wirklich, Andreas sagt es uns. Wir waren gerade dabei wo?
Wir waren gerade dabei, zu sagen, was nach den Nachrichten kommt, weil ihr braucht jetzt erstmal nicht anrufen, weil vor dem Fritz-Info werden wir sowieso nicht mehr telefonieren, aber ihr könnt natürlich danach wieder anklingeln. 0331 für Potsdam, 74 81 110 ist unsere Nummer hier im Studio. Und nach den Nachrichten werden wir worüber reden?
Ja, ich hoffe über AmiExpress, Amiga, Kopiererszene, Leute, die sich damit befasst haben, Leute, die davon Bescheid wissen, die welches Modem ist das Beste? Welches Modem ist das Beste?
Und wer hier sagt jetzt einer Zeichsel?
Welche Settings waren die besten, um nach X zu telefonieren, über Y und hast du nicht gesehen? Genau diese Themen, das würde mich brennend interessieren.
Wir haben jeden Tag die aktuellen ROMs aus der Mailbox in Taiwan geholt.
Da gab es jeden Tag eine neue Version.
Da gab es nicht jeden Tag eine neue Version, aber wir haben jeden Tag gekoppt.
Wir haben noch die halb, wir müssen noch ein bisschen quasseln.
Nee, wir können noch einen MPEG spielen.
Das überfordert Tobias.
Bis gleich. Ebenfalls MPEG 3 Formats.
Wenn übrigens MPEG 3 ist, ist das MPEG 2 Layer 3. Und ich nochmal ganz kurz...
Entschuldigung, nein, das ist völlig okay, wenn ich da technische Fehler mache. MPEG 2 Layer 3. Im Chat fragt sich gerade jemand, ob sich hier jemand MP3 mit Linux macht. Natürlich ist Linux.
Ja genau, das tun wir die ganze Zeit.
Also MP3, die ganzen MP3 Files werden von einem Linux PC abgespielt.
Also von einem Notebook, auf dem Linux läuft.
Was für ein Programm ist das denn, was man da braucht?
Das ist in diesem Falle AMP. Den gibt es zum Beispiel bei FTP, Sunsight, UNC, Edu.
Kann man sich den runterziehen und kompilieren.
Und ansonsten für Windows gibt es auch fertig kompilierte Binaries. Für Linux muss man die dann halt selber kompilieren, aber das sollte ja kein Problem darstellen.
Wie viel Windows unter Linux für X-Windows oder was meinst du jetzt?
Windows 95.
Aber das ist eigentlich ein Thema von nachher, ne?
Stimmt ja, ja genau. Was ist jetzt nochmal Thema? Ich frage mal jemanden, der von da ist.
AmiExpress, AmiExpress, das ist ein Kauserwort.
Hi, hier ist Chaosradio. Wer ist denn da? Matthias, bist du ein Amiga-Benutzer? Sag mal, was ist mit euren Chatbots?
Ich versuche hier schon stundenlang reinzukommen.
Ja, läuft hier auch.
Ja, ich war ja schon auf der Seite, wo mein Text irgendwie nicht zu euch ist.
Was hast du denn für einen Browser?
Ach so, damit könnte es Probleme geben.
Damit kann es Probleme geben.
Du brauchst JavaScript, so viel, wie ich weiß.
Nee, das ist kein Java-Chat, soweit ich weiß. Kann sein, dass der da gibt es oft, also bei...
Du musst vielleicht öfter mal auf Reload klicken, weil der Browser das nicht automatisch macht.
Versuch das mal. Ansonsten, man kann aber OWL auch so einrichten, dass man Netscape fahren kann. Ach so, dann müsste es eigentlich gehen. Wobei, weiß ich nicht.
Bandbreiten ist ein Problem. Bestimmt ein Bandbreiten.
Siehst du denn die anderen? Also, das Reload funktioniert, du siehst immer wieder neue Zeilen.
Hm, komisch.
Wie heißt denn du? Nee, ich meine jetzt hier im Chat.
Wie?
Warte mal. Ich guck mal, ob ich dich hier hab irgendwo. Nö, nicht zu sehen.
Hörer-Supporter und das umsonst.
Hey, allerdings. Wir sind hier als Microsoft hier.
Und ihr zahlt kein Fennich aus dem IGZ.
Nee, BIF. Wir können uns auf dem nächsten Sinn noch mal versuchen. Siehste, was sind wir nett hier. 0331 für Potsdam 74, 81, 110. Für alle Fragen des Lebens sind wir auf dem Chaos Computer Club bei Fritz. Eigentlich wollen wir aber mit über die Amiga-Szene reden. Warum ist die Amiga-Szene eigentlich da so weit vorne?
Naja, der Amiga war das erste wirklich billige, interessante, verfügbare Multitasking-Betriebssystem. Der konnte Sound, der konnte...
Das einzige.
Naja, nicht das einzige. Das ist gar nicht richtig, Caro. Aber es war das, dass man auch bezahlen konnte. Es war damals nicht das einzige Multitasking-Betriebssystem, es war das einzige, das man bezahlen konnte.
Und das einzige, was getaugt hat.
Ja, okay. Vielleicht haben wir hier ja einen Amiga-User dran. Hi, wer ist denn da? Hier ist Chaos Radio. Hallo?
Ja, ich wollte erst mal was Grundsätzliches zum CCC fragen. Wie kann man euch denn mal kontaktieren? Also, ich hab euch schon angemailt und krieg irgendwie keine Antwort von euch.
Ja, du, das tut uns leid, aber es klappt nicht immer, dass wir alle wirklich alle alle alle Anfragen beantworten, wenn...
Hast du dann eigentlich hingemeldet?
Genau, gute Frage.
Also, die Adresse weiß ich jetzt nicht auswendig, aber es war hier so eine Berliner Mailadresse, die ihr auf unserer Seite habt.
Schreibt mal an, das ist übrigens auch unsere Allgemeine für diese Sendung hier, chaos.orb.de.
Ich glaube, die Adresse, die auf den Seiten ist, das landet alles bei Tim und Tim ist im Urlaub und das staut sich in seinem Mailfolder.
Das kann gut angehen, ja.
Ich glaube, das ist die Erklärung für das Thema.
Weil chaos.orb.de kommt an viele Leute, also an einige, die hier mit der Sendung zu tun haben und da ist dann die Wahrscheinlichkeit höher, dass irgendjemand darauf antwortet.
Aber ihr habt doch auch Treffen hier in Berlin oder habe ich das falsch verstanden?
Das ist richtig, wir treffen uns und jetzt übernehme ich mal den Part von Anja, der sonst immer hier sitzt und das rezitiert. Jeden Dienstag um 21 Uhr in der Neuen Schönhause, Nummer 20 und ganz oben.
Ja, da war ich nämlich schon mal und da habe ich nichts gefunden, da hängt kein Schild, nichts.
Das ist doch konspirativ.
Deswegen sagen wir auch die Adresse im Radio.
Meine Konto-Nummer übrigens.
Also es hat sich mittlerweile eingebürgert, dass die Treffen um 21 Uhr anfangen, nicht um 20 Uhr und öfter mal ist auch um 20 Uhr noch gar keiner da. Man muss nach ganz oben und man muss nach ganz hinten.
Da darf man aber auch schon mal als Nicht-Mitglied kommen, oder?
Das sieht nur gefährlich aus.
Das ist immer ein bisschen schwierig, weil da sitzen halt lauter Leute, die sich echt lang und echt gut kennen. Und dann sitzt dann einer, den kennt keiner. Und das ist immer ein komisches Gefühl. Also je offener und je direkter man da drauf zugeht und da keine Berührungsängste hat, umso einfacher ist das auch. Das ist für uns ja auch nicht leicht.
Aber ich finde, ihr habt heute Abend echt ein interessantes Thema. Und wollte dazu auch nochmal was sagen. Also ich habe mir das in letzter Zeit, bin letztes Mal durch das Thema inspiriert worden. Habe mir also seitangeguckt und bin sehr durch das Thema der Sendung inspiriert worden. Habe mir das mal ein bisschen angeguckt. Bin also noch ziemlich neu in der Sache und habe also festgestellt, dass bei mir meine Erfahrungen alle völlig entschärft waren. Also ich habe mir dann auch mal so ein paar Sachen runtergezogen aus dem Internet und hauptsächlich festgestellt, dass es also Demo-Versionen von Programmen waren, die ich auch direkt von den Herstellern bekommen habe. Naja, so auf diversen Hacker-Seiten, auf irgendwelchen Wares-Seiten, die ich gerade so zufällig gefunden habe.
Ich denke, man muss da halt auch differenzieren. Es gibt da halt diese Seiten, die jeder halt anlegen kann und dann Seiten, die du wirklich suchen musst, damit du sie findest. Es ist selbst schwer, wenn du da irgendwie dein Geld mitverdienst, dir Internetseiten anzugucken, so manche Seiten zu finden. Ich kann immer nur sagen, es gibt alles, was du suchst im Internet. Wirklich alles. Und du musst nur lange genug suchen oder warten. Irgendwann wird es verfügbar sein und du wirst es irgendwann irgendwo finden.
Und dann kommt auch die 78.
Diskette auf altbeinig.grsp.gm.pc Naja, also ich war ein bisschen enttäuscht von der ganzen Sache.
Das ist aber glaube ich auch ganz gut. Aber stell dir vor, es würde wirklich jeder tun, der im Internet irgendwie zugange ist. Also wirklich jeder würde irgendwie Raub kopieren und Raubkopien anbieten, sehen, traden. Dann würde auch das Ganze verloren gehen.
Vor allem würden die ganzen Softwarefirmen dann wirklich pleite gehen.
Das ist wahr. Und das geht dann schon richtig mit beschäftigen und irgendwie richtig Arbeit reinstecken. Ich denke, du wirst es halt nicht, du wirst nicht drüber stoppen und sagen, oops, da ist ja eine Raubkopie. Nein, du musst schon etwas länger suchen.
Bei unseren Recherchen haben wir festgestellt, dass wenn man einen gut bezahlten Job hätte und würde die gleiche Zeit, die man jetzt mal da sucht, diesen Job machen, könnte man sich für das Geld, das man dabei verdient, die Software kaufen. Also so richtig rentieren tut sich es nicht. Man muss schon ein bisschen fanatisch sein.
Ja, ich habe so einen ähnlichen Job. Ich habe einen Job, wo man wenig zu tun hat und umsonst im Internet surfen kann und auch die nötige Bandbreite hat. Nein, nein, es ist schon in Ordnung. Ich habe ein bisschen gesucht und war von dem, was ich gefunden habe, ziemlich enttäuscht. Ich kann mir natürlich vorstellen, dass die ganzen öffentlichen Server, auf denen ich war, die ständig besetzt sind, die haben ja nur eine bestimmte Quota an Leuten, die zugelassen werden, natürlich von den hohen Hackern, von den hohen Tieren irgendwie ständig benutzt werden können und von mir als Anonymous-User nicht zugänglich sind. Das kann ich mir natürlich schon vorstellen.
Probier mal folgendes. Zieh dir einfach so eine Demo-Version von irgendetwas, was du gerne hättest und die lassen sich ja dann meistens durch das Eintippen der Registrier-Nummer zu einer echten Version machen und dann suche einfach nach der passenden Registrier-Nummer. Beides ist mit Sicherheit zu finden.
Mal eine ganz andere Frage. Du sagtest von den Hohen Herren Hackern, was denkst du denn, wen du damit jetzt angesprochen hast? Was für Leute denkst du denn, tun denn solches und blockieren solche Server? Meinst du, die kennen sich alle? Das hört du sich so an.
Also denke ich schon. Zumindest Kreise gibt es, die sich auf jeden Fall sehr gut kennen. Ich bin ja auch schon seit 20 Jahren Computerfreak und habe mit dem 64er angefangen. Und kenne das von daher auch noch. Bin dann jetzt noch mal dahin zurückgekommen und habe halt eigentlich festgestellt, dass es immer noch so ist. Das ist also, denke ich jetzt mal, großen und ganzen Jugendliche sind so im Alter von 15 bis 20, die vielleicht die großen Gruppen noch einen Kopf haben, der alles ein bisschen unter Kontrolle hat, die schon richtig Geschäfte damit machen. Aber im Grunde genommen ist es, glaube ich, so die Faszination und im Geheimnis und an dem, was verboten ist zu tun und die Spannung halt hierbei.
Das würde mich mal interessieren, was andere Leute noch darüber denken. Weil ich denke, dann können wir auch mal offen darüber reden oder versuchen offen darüber zu reden, was vielleicht wir darüber denken. Aber ich würde mich wirklich interessiert aus einfach, was die Leute darüber denken. Das ist schon sehr interessant. Finde ich klasse, dass du das mal...
Haben wir nicht da draußen irgendwo einen Softwarehersteller, der jetzt wutschnaupt auf Radio sitzt und sagt, sag mal, sind die alle total verrückt?
Ja, ich hätte recht, die müssen mal auf das Sprechen.
Das ist eine Abteilung von Microsoft zum Beispiel. Die haben auch neulich an die legalen registrierten Anwender ihrer Programme bitterböse Briefe geschrieben, dass Unternehmen, die Rob-Kopien einsetzen, doch strafförig sind und auch sie als Unternehmen im Verdacht haben, denn sie haben ja legale Kopien gekauft. Wer sagt denn, dass sie davon nicht weitere Kopien gemacht haben, für den Rechnern einsetzen?
Aber da sind wir doch bei einem völlig neuen Thema, nämlich wie ist es denn mit denen, die die Software jetzt wirklich kommerziell einsetzen, eine Version kaufen und in einem Betrieb mit 50, 60 Leuten, 60 Rechnern, da die Software wirklich auch drauf zum Laufen haben?
Ist das im Netz nicht sehr schwierig? Also ich meine, an sich im Netz, ich kenne es nur von Macintosh Netzen, dass da immer die Seriennummer abgefragt wird.
Ja, naja, du, wenn man sie einbaut.
Bei PC ist das erstmal nicht so.
Das müsste gar nicht funktionieren.
Ja, wollen wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen weitergehen, nochmal hören, was so andere Leute zu sagen haben?
Ich finde die Frage nach dem, ich sag dir schon mal Tschüss, ja Jan? Ich finde die Frage nach dem, wie man sich eigentlich, weiß ich nicht, Hacker oder Leute, die mit Wares handeln oder so vorstellt, auch ganz interessant, denn ich fand's vorhin auch gar nicht so weit von der Realität weg, als wir gesagt haben, es müssen Leute sein, die ihren Lebensunterhalt noch nicht verdienen müssen, weil es ist einfach eine super zeitintensive Sache und auch der Vergleich mit, wenn ich für die Zeit jetzt bezahlt worden wäre, hätte ich mir die Software kaufen können. Mal abgesehen davon, wie lange es auch jetzt noch mit ISDN und dem ganzen Quatsch dauert, eine wirklich große und damit auch teure Software runterzuladen, also weiß ich nicht. Zum Beispiel hat mir jemand erzählt, dass die neue Director-Version irgendwie 6.0 22 Megabit, ich meine, wir zieten sich sowas.
Na ja, also an der Uni kann man sich das ziehen.
Stell dir vor, du arbeitest in einer Firma mit Internetanschluss und da startest du das abends und morgens kommst du wieder und dann liegen die 22 Megabyte da frisch um.
Ah, da ist keiner mehr dran, das war jetzt jemand aus einer Firma, der jetzt mal in einer Firma anruft, ob da noch jemand am Sackeln ist. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio, wer ist da?
Bin ich jetzt Frau?
Ihr wundert euch jetzt, wer sich da irgendwie große Dateien runterlädt. Also ich hab vor zwei Wochen oder wann das war, hab ich mir Photoshop runtergezogen und das ist eine Datei von 27 Megabytes. Als ich es dann komplett gekriegt hab, war ich vier Stunden dran und das war aber schon der vierte oder fünfte Versuch.
Und vorher hat es immer abgebrochen.
Und wie bist du ans Internet angebunden? Über die Uni. Also du hast es auch in die Uni sozusagen gezogen.
Ja, ich hab's in der Uni zuerst versucht, aber da hat das nicht geklappt. Da hat er immer zwischendurch abgebrochen, beziehungsweise beim zweiten Versuch, naja, Murphy's Gesetz, ein halbes Megabyte vor Schluss, Verbindung unterbrochen.
Hast du schon mal was von ReGet gehört? ReGet ist nämlich ein wenig bekanntes Feature von FTP, Clients und Servern. Man kann dann an einer Stelle, wo er abgebrochen hat, weitermachen. Das geht leider bei HTTP nicht, aber bei FTP geht das gelegentlich.
Da siehst du wieder was dazugelernt. Auch die HTTP-Verbindung, also über das Web solche Dinge ziehen, ist echt quark, weil das macht man dann mit NetScape oder Explorer und die sind da nicht so prickelnd.
Frank, wie ziehst du denn die Sachen unter FTP?
Die sind über FTP gekommen, ja.
Und nicht in einem Browser, also nicht in einem WWW-Browser, sondern in einer Shell sozusagen.
Ja, also mit einem eigenen FTP-Client.
Genau, also RTFM, Mann, FTP und da steht das drin.
Also da geht das, dass du dann, wenn ein Download abgebrochen ist, dass du den da wieder, dass die schon vorhandenen Daten bei dir, dass die benutzt werden, dass du also nicht nochmal von vorne anfangen musst. Da musst du mal, wenn das eine eigene Software ist, musst du mal im Handbuch gucken, ob das geht, oder kurz lernen, das ist nicht allzu schwer, wie man das unter einer Unix Shell direkt eintippt, dann geht das alles.
Ja, aber so wie ich das festgestellt hab, hat er die Daten auch gar nicht irgendwie dann gespeichert, auf der Festplatte. Also ich hab geguckt, ob da irgendwie diese kaputte Datei oder unvorständige Datei irgendwo da rumliegt, aber ich hab den nicht gefunden.
Hast du das unter Unix gemacht oder unter Windows?
Das war unter Windows.
Solltest du mal das Betriebssystem den FDP-Client wechseln? Also es gibt durchaus Programme, die das richtig machen.
Betriebssystem wechseln, ja klar.
Quake läuft auch unter Linux, man muss es einfach mal wieder sagen.
Gar nicht schlecht.
Na gut, für Quake habe ich jetzt unter DOS schon Probleme. Na gut, aber ich nehme an, das wird wahrscheinlich nicht schneller werden.
Das ist richtig.
So verdammt langsam gewesen bei mir, dass ich mit keinem Bock mehr hatte auf das Spiel.
Dein Computer ist nicht schnell genug.
Das ist richtig.
Na, veralte, das ist ja schon mindestens, weiss ich nicht, das hast du doch schon seit einem halben Jahr, oder?
Ja, wir sind zwei Jahre.
Ich merke, da hast du aber mal richtig Geld herausgegeben, oder?
Ey, da darf man überhaupt nicht anfangen, darüber zu reden.
Dass der überhaupt noch läuft.
Was war ich bei Alte? Dass ich meinen 2.86.12 gekriegt habe und der war einfach dreimal so schnell wie mein XT.
So, wo waren wir eigentlich?
Bei den alten Zeiten waren wir eigentlich.
Erstmal Frank, wie stellst du dir denn Leute vor, die sich so viel mit Waze beschäftigen? Ich muss zum Beispiel von mir sagen, es gibt Leute, die ich wirklich bewundere, und das sind die, die wirklich die Cracks machen für Programme. Also die zum Beispiel nur so ein kleines Patch schreiben, dass ich, weiß ich nicht, ich habe eine Version, die läuft nicht, weil da ist ein Schutz drin oder es ist die Demo-Version und ich starte ein kleines Programm, was von mir aus 50 Kilobyte hat oder so und schon läuft das Ding. Und da muss ich sagen Hut ab, also da, das beeindruckt mich doch wahrscheinlich, weil ich keine Ahnung habe, wie es geht. Das beeindruckt ja immer.
Also ich stelle mir vor, das müssen halt Leute sein, die praktisch binären Code direkt so lesen können. Oder die, was weiß ich, mit irgendeinem Disassembler irgendwie die Excel-Datei bearbeiten und dann gucken, boah, was steht denn da? Und das muss weg und das muss umgeändert werden. Und das ist ich.
Das hat ein bisschen was mit Sendmeditation zu tun.
Und dann läuft das alles.
Ja, Andreas, erklär doch mal, wie geht denn sowas?
Das ist ein bisschen Voodoo-Zauber, ne?
Das erste Problem ist, das Programm in die Burger reinzukriegen. Also in ein Programm reinzuladen, zwischen Betriebssystem und dem eigentlichen Programm, mit dem man die Ausführung des Programms kontrollieren kann. Und dann sieht man halt, da drückt man halt Ctrl-C an der Stelle, wo die Codes kommen, oder man geht schrittweise von Anfang durch und guckt, wann das passiert. Und nach einer Zeit kann man sich halt in den Code reinarbeiten. Kann man also anfangen zu verstehen, was bestimmte Code-Strukturen bedeuten, warum da Codes sind, welche Abfragen da sind. Und dann findet man nach einer Weile halt die Stelle, wo das steht, und dann ist dann ein Sprungbefehl, ein conditional jump, also erst ein Vergleich, hat das gestimmt oder nicht. Und danach ist ein Jump-if-zero, und wenn man aus dem Jump-if-zero einen Jump macht, der immer jumpt, dann funktioniert das Programm plötzlich immer.
Ja, und dann gibt es noch die komplizierten, wie Autokart, 3D Max, die dann auf irgendwelche Dongles zugreifen.
Mit Dongles habe ich die Erfahrung gemacht, dass sie meistens eine Dongle-Library benutzen, und da die IsDongle-thehr-Funktion aufrufen, und danach Jump-if-zero und das selbe.
Ja, das ist schon richtig gemein, aber jetzt gerade Fast Electronics macht sich da deutlich mehr Mühe.
Ich habe auch schon Fast gesehen, der so eingebunden war.
Problematisch wird es halt nur, wenn der Code dann im Dongle ist.
Mittlerweile funktioniert das dann auch so, dass da eine Zahl an den Dongle geschickt wird, der rechnet was ausgibt, das Ergebnis zurück, und wenn das Ergebnis nicht stimmt, wird die Software nicht weiter ausgibt.
Gut, dann hast du aber auch ein BEQ Branch-Equal. Natürlich, es gibt immer einen Weg. Es gab damals schon unknackbare Software auf dem C64, auf dem Amiga, wo es immer hieß.
Die beste Strategie, die ich bis jetzt hatte, war der Kopierschutz mit dem Kratzer auf der Diskette, wo das System feststellte, ob er auf eine definierten Stelle auf der Diskette schreiben konnte, und wenn das ging, war es die falsche Diskette.
Ja, beim Amiga waren die Disketten dann gelocht teilweise. Oder sie haben einfach Longtracks benutzt, was dann so viel hieß, dass man die nur mit Verlangsamen des Motors im Diskettenslaufwerk schreiben konnte.
Atari, noch einen Atari zum besten Starglider. Der war total mies. Das war die einzige, das war eine geile 3D-Game-Software. Die lief auf dem Amiga und auf dem Atari und benutze die gleiche Database. Aber halt unterschiedliche Programme. Das ging deswegen, weil der Amiga und der Atari von jeweils der anderen Diskettenseite bootete. Und beim Atari benutzten sie einen Feature Read Track. Und das konnte der Controller eigentlich gar nicht, weil das ein Controller mit Bug war. Aber das braucht er auch normalerweise nicht. Und die haben das da trotzdem gemacht. Und wir sind bald verzweifelt und haben nicht rausgekriegt, wie sie das gemacht haben, bis wir dann halt irgendwann auf die Lösung kamen, dass sie einfach gnadenlos x-mal versuchen, bis sie mal synchronisiert werden. So mit Brutforce. Das war echt der wüsteste Kompierschutz, den ich jetzt gefunden habe.
Stein, du hast sowas also getan. Das würde ich noch mal ganz kurz...
Ja, super, jetzt habe ich auch keinen Respekt mehr von dir. Jetzt weiß ich ja, wie es geht. Total gute Beschreibung. Easy. Frank weiß auch Bescheid jetzt.
Dann müssen wir uns noch ein paar Grüße loswerden. Und zwar sind wir...
Wir grüßen mal alle, hallo.
Wünschst du dir auch noch ein Lied?
Ich wünsche mir auch gleich noch ein Lied, ja. Und zwar zu Wende-strich-strich-Nachwende-Zeiten. Im Osten gab es zwei regelmäßige Treffs jede Woche, wo dann 20 Amigas mit X-Copy liegen und ein PC mit Discopy. Und es war einmal im Fez und zum anderen im HDJT. Und ich grüße alle Leute, die damals da waren. Insbesondere grüße ich Roy und Sinek und Wengler. Und wenn ihr am Radio seid, ruft doch mal an.
Ach komm, dann müssen wir jetzt aber auch die Runde komplett machen. Dann fangen wir gleich mal an. Dann wollen wir doch gleich den Amok grüßen, den Rocks küssen. Ach klar, klar, muss jetzt sein.
Wir haben ja Jahre nicht gesehen, die Leute noch.
Das ist richtig, das ist richtig. Also mit Ausnahmen jetzt von zwei, drei Leuten. Die, die ich jetzt gegrüßt habe, hören sicherlich zu. Aber es gibt Leute, da habe ich den Kontakt einfach verloren. Und ich hoffe, dass sie zuhören. In der Modem-Zähne wäre das kein Problem gewesen. Da wäre das irgendwie eine Mail aus Bulletin Board und dann wäre das rum. Und alle würden sie am Radio kleben. Heutzutage benutzen wir E-Mail, Caro. Ja, das Problem ist, es gibt keine E-Mail-Verteiler, wo sich nicht jeder eintragen könnte. Und das ist halt das Problem. Es gibt solche E-Mail-Verteiler immer noch. Ich habe ja auch in der Formel, die hier rumgegangen ist, zum Chaosradio ein paar E-Mail-Adressen oder URLs publiziert, wo auch solche E-Mail-Verteiler sozusagen abgebildet waren. Aber es ist einfach so, im Internet ist man anonym. Da kann man nicht wissen, wer der andere ist. Und das ist halt schon was anderes als früher.
So, und jetzt wünsche ich mir ein Lied. Und zwar den Mission Impossible Soundtrack mit MP3. Doch!
Kommt er?
Tatsächlich.
Wir werden jetzt schneller telefonieren. Das heißt, wir reden schneller mit euch und schmeißen euch schneller raus. Hi, wer ist denn da?
Hallo, wer ist da?
Mann, Kinder, wenn ihr im Telefonhörer auf einmal Radio hört, dann seid ihr praktisch schon reingeschaltet. Dann braucht ihr nicht mehr warten. Ah, oder auflegen oder so. Vor lauter Schreck. Und es gibt auch keine Vorabhöre. Ihr kommt immer direkt hier gleich zu uns. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hier ist Chaosradio. Marco, hallo.
Ja, ich bin einer der einsamen Mac-Husern.
Hey, gar nicht einsam.
Ja gut, ich muss mal sagen, bei uns läuft es irgendwo noch ein bisschen anders als in der ganzen PC-Branche. Bei uns werden die großen Daten eigentlich immer noch so parant rüber gehen. Das hätte nur sehr gereicht oder mal eine brandne CD. Und von daher, irgendwo in dieser Wuss mit irgendwelchen Handbüchern und so, wird ihnen erklärt, wie funktioniert das Programm.
Marco, hast du einen Internetzugang?
Ja auch, ja.
Sony gibt jetzt einen Quellenpreis.
Ich sag nur ein Wort und das heißt Hotline.
Er hat es gesagt, er hat es gut gesagt.
Und das ist das einzige Wort, was du brauchst. Mehr braucht man nicht.
Genau, und dann kriegst du alles, was du brauchst.
Aber es ist ja auch nett, sich noch zu sehen dabei und sich was in die Hand zu drücken. Wie gehst du denn mit größeren Teilen um? Arbeitest du beruflich mit deinem Mac?
Nee, ich muss eigentlich sagen, in letzter Zeit nur privat. Ich hab vorher mal ein bisschen was gemacht beruflich.
Ok, aber jetzt gibt's irgendeinen Kumpel, der eine neue Photoshop Version hat. Die brauchst du vielleicht gar nicht, weil das Programm so umfangreich ist, dass du damit eigentlich nicht so was machen willst. Bist du trotzdem neugierig da drauf?
Ja, dann hab ich die eigentlich auch schon fast immer. Aus dem Grund, weil ich da auch ein bisschen an der Anlaufstelle bin, für Sammler, wer was haben will. Und wie gesagt, ich muss sagen, sammeln, haben, benutzen, also das, was ich wirklich benutze, das sind eigentlich alles Sachen, die man wirklich selber hat. Also ein bisschen einfache Sachen, ja. Was ich aber eigentlich besser finde, sind so kleine Shareware-Anbieter mal zu unterstützen. Wie gesagt, ein Mac-User sagt wahrscheinlich, der Grafikkonzert da was, ja. Tolle Sache und die 50 Mark, die der haben will, die hat er voll verdient. Das finde ich okay. Es gibt Leute, die behaupten, Software herstellen, ist wie Geld selber drucken. Mag bei Microsoft vielleicht stimmen.
Das war früher mal so, ja.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Also ich selber mache sowas nicht. Aber die Clienten, da sollte man schon, die unterstützen, wenn man sie regelmäßig nutzt.
Also da sind wir wieder beim Schlüsselwort Fairness. Das heißt, du sagst dir, da stellt ein Typ ein Shareware-Programm her, was eine unheimliche Menge an Funktionen hat, was ansonsten große Grafikprogramme machen. Ich kann alles damit tun, was ich jetzt für meine Zwecke brauche und der W50 Mark haben und die soll er haben, weil ich arbeite jetzt da seit einem halben Jahr mit und benutze das Ding einfach regelmäßig. Und das ist eine reine Fairness-Frage. Also es gibt bestimmt Leute, die haben das Programm, die neueste Version seit drei Jahren in Benutzung und denken aber gar nicht dran.
Ja gut, aber genauso ist ja, wie Kai Krause sagt, ich habe sicherlich auch was. Seine Auffassung ist ja gut, Raubkopie ok, schön und gut, aber solange er das für sich selber benutzt, sehe ich das allen und sobald er mit Geld verdient, dann möchte er auch was bezahlen. Ich finde das total ok, auch diese ganze Raubkopiererei, solange man wirklich kein Geld verdient. Also wenn es anfängt, dass man Geld verdienen will, dann möchte man sowas doch irgendwo schon betahlen.
Zumal ja auch die Strategie von Kai Krauses, Metatools heißt die Firma, glaube ich, oder Meta-Design, die bringen nun ihre Software auch relativ günstig auf den Markt. Also da fängt man dann wirklich an zu zweifeln, ok, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, aber ziemlich Raubkopier unfreundlich für den Markt zumindest. Ich habe das ein paar Mal probiert, es geht einfach nicht, weil der bringt das auf eine CD raus und hat auf der CD eine Datei, die unsichtbar ist.
Ah, das ist doch leicht. Auf ein, auf ein, auf ein.
Er hat die CD in zwei Laufzeiten aufgeteilt.
Du musst dir wie gesagt bei allem nur Mühe geben, dann geht das schon.
Aber muss ja auch nicht sein, ich finde, also die Software ist ja wirklich relativ günstig im Gegensatz zu anderen Geschichten.
Das andere Ding ist eben beim Markt, dass es eben sehr viele Demo-Versionen gibt, die man eigentlich als Demo gar nicht bezeichnen kann. Das sind wirklich nur zum reingucken und man kann dabei überhaupt nichts anfangen.
Ja, aber dazu muss man sehen, es gibt genauso Demo-Programme, mit denen du alles machen kannst.
Ja sicher, sicher, aber es gibt eine ganze Menge. Ich sag mal jetzt zum Beispiel Photoshop, ja? Sehr weit verbreitetes Programm. Wenn ich aber diese Style-Setting-Try-Out-Versionen, wenn ich mir die angucke, da weiß ich überhaupt noch nicht, da habe ich noch gar nicht richtig erfahren, wie das Programm funktioniert. Dann bin ich schon irgendwo fast gezwungen, mir einen Raubkopf zu ziehen, mir das Programm richtig ordentlich anzugucken und dann zu entscheiden, koffe ich es oder koffe ich es nicht.
Was glaubst du, wie wird sich das weiterentwickeln in Zukunft jetzt mit Java-Applets und einer Strategie von den Softwarefirmen? Wird das so sein, dass die Softwarefirmen sagen, okay, wir machen das mehr so Richtung Shareware oder wird es viele kleine Softwarefirmen geben, die im Internet zum Beispiel, wenn es mal ein Microtrading, also das Bezahlen von kleinen Summen im Internet gibt, die sagen, wir verkaufen unsere Software wie Metatools für billig, weil wir einfach keine Werbe und keine Vertriebskosten mehr haben, weil es ja schon so ist, dass Software verkaufen wie Geld drucken ist. Du kopierst es, du hast keinen Aufwand dabei, so etwas zu kopieren und wenn du zwei davon hast, kannst du zwei verkaufen. Wenn du tausend hast, kannst du tausend verkaufen. Du kannst ja beliebig viele neue Programme machen, die du verkaufen kannst.
Ja, in meinen Augen ist das Problem, dass die Großen damit nicht zurecht kommen werden, aus dem einfachen Grund, weil ihre, ich sag mal so, die, die jetzt richtig groß sind, so eine gigantische Programme haben, wo sie ja wirklich ewig lange dran sitzen und auch mit vielen Leuten, dass sie das preislich gar nicht hinkriegen werden. Das sind denn wirklich diese kleinen Sachen. Die werden sicherlich laufen, aus dem einfachen Grund, weil die mit wirklich kleinen speziellen Sachen günstig entwickeln können und trotzdem da, wie gesagt, mit zu integrierten Paketen sehr gut am Markt vertreten sein werden. Und die werden sich das sicherlich zu vernünftigen Preisen zahlen lassen können. Und da wäre ich hoch bereit, das zu bezahlen. Aber wie gesagt, was soll ich da, so ein Word, irgendwann mal 8.0, was mir meine Festplatte vollmüllt, geht nicht mehr, bezahlen, wo ich ja wirklich nicht mal 10% von brauche.
Marco, klares Wort. Danke dir erstmal. Wollen wir mal langsam zu diesen Soundgeschichten kommen? Oder wollt ihr weiter telefonieren erstmal? Das sind Massehörer da.
Lachen sie mal schnell durch.
Hallo, wie heißt du? Ach, Christian.
Ich wollte nur mal sagen, dass diese großen Firmen, dass es ja für die auch Werbung ist, wenn da eine Raubkopie gezogen wird. Das geht ja durch Hunderte, durch Tausende Hände. Und wenn da genug Leute dransitzen, die auch was zu sagen haben, uns ausprobieren und es für gut befinden, denn später vielleicht in der Firma offiziell sich lizenzieren lassen, dass es ja für die Firma in dem Moment eine kostenlose Werbung war.
Ich glaube auch, dass wenn es Raubkopien nicht gäbe, dass die Umsätze zurückgehen würden. Das habe ich mich fest von überzeugt.
Gibt es auch Studien drüber übrigens? Ja, gibt es. Kann ich noch mal auf die URL zurückkommen, die ich gepostet hatte. Da gibt es den einen oder anderen Bericht von dem einen Juristen, gleich am Anfang. Wie weit die Zahlen dann runtergehen wollen, ich habe sie leider nicht im Kopf.
Übrigens, wer auf die Chaosradio Mailinglist will, wer also einen Internetzugang hat oder eine E-Mail-Adresse oder jemand kennt mit E-Mail-Adresse, der kann das über eine Mail an chaos.orb.de ganz einfach machen. Kann aber ein bisschen dauern, weil es immer im Urlaub ist. Christian?
Ja, es gab ja auch schon viele Shareware-Sachen, die dadurch auch richtig hochgekommen sind. Also es gab ja, oder es gibt ja viele Beispiele. Mir jetzt nicht ganz so geläufig, aber ich habe schon öfters drüber gelesen, dass viele aus der Shareware-Richtung kamen und dadurch, dass sie in gut weit verbreitet waren. Also Paintshop, nur vielleicht ein schlechtes Beispiel, aber ich denke, es ist ein kleines Programm, das jeder hat und das, wie gesagt, auch einen Erfolg mit sich brachte, dass es eben jeder hatte.
Zoom als populärstes Beispiel, die sind echt reich geworden.
Christian, vielen Dank.
Weiter telefonieren?
Weiter. Weiter telefonieren, weiter. Hi, wer ist denn da?
Ja hallo, hier ist der Kai.
Du klingst komischerweise bei manchen Leuten schon bei den ersten drei Worten, was einen erwartet, Kai. Glaubst du, du kannst diesen Eindruck von mir rückgängig machen?
Das kann passieren.
Ah, versuch's.
Na ja, das ist leider nicht gelungen.
Schade eigentlich, Kai.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Wer ist denn da?
Ich dachte, er macht eine Schnellrunde. Hier ist eine Beitragsforschnellrunde, die wichtigste Adresse, wo es Wehr ausgibt, ist stp.wehraus.org.
Das ist wohl richtig, ja. Er hat es gesagt.
Gut, dann haben wir das nicht gesagt.
Felix, danke.
Ei, und jetzt wird der Chat gleich voll regnen mit Weißte, wer gesagt hat?
Wie sagt man das? Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Wer ist da?
Niemand.
0331 für Potsdam, 74, 81, 1310, Suppi, gleich verwählt. Wann fangen wir an mit den Sounds, oder soll ich weiter telefonieren?
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Chaosradio.
Hallo, ich bin Stefan, oder Case kann man auch sagen.
Oh, Stefan.
Also aus der ehemaligen C-Szene oder H-T-Szene.
Was ist das?
Das hat der Andreas eben angemahnt.
Das war doch garantiert schon wieder ein Irrg, ne?
Was hast du abgetreten?
Ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Der Case ist hier.
Ja, nee.
Aus der H-T-Szene oder aus der F-E-Z-Szene.
Aus dieser ganz alten Szene, was gerade gesagt wurde.
Da hat Andreas drüber geredet, ja. Davon hab ich aber keinen Schimmer. Muss ich mit Andreas antworten.
Johnny hat's nicht mitgekriegt, erklissen.
Na ja, das ist zu dieser, ich sag mal, Nachwendezeit, wo dort eben, wie gesagt, mehrere Computer, also ab Amiga oder PC und reine Kopierstationen waren.
Ach so, das, ja.
Darauf hab ich mitgekriegt.
Genau, da hat er ja einige Leute gegrüßt. Mich hat er nicht gegrüßt, aber macht nichts, macht nichts.
Ich hab nicht mehr alle Namen zusammengekriegt.
Ja, ist schon ordentlich.
Aber ihr kennt euch demnach wahrscheinlich.
Ich hab mich bei den Namen auch angesprochen, gefühlt.
Ihr kennt euch demnach wahrscheinlich, vom Sehen zumindest.
Ich denke, wenn wir uns sehen würden, würden wir uns wiedererkennen.
Davon gehe ich immer auch fest aus, ja.
Hast du ein bisschen wie bitte melde dich hier jetzt.
Nee, also ich, das war so damals, Chaos Computer Club, das ist ja noch die Zeit, sag ich mal, H2HT, da waren so die ersten Berührungspunkte. Als noch, ich sag mal, so die ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz alten vom Chaos Computer Club aus Hamburg damals Kukorn eingefallen sind.
Na Moment, Moment, das waren nicht Leute aus Hamburg, das waren schon wir.
Na, das waren auch Hamburger.
Das war genau ein Hamburger, ja.
Ja, aber auch es ist rumgerannt.
Na, es waren schon mehrere.
Ist ja auch egal, aber auf jeden Fall waren wir dabei.
Ja, genau.
Ja, hast du eigentlich die Szene nach der Zeit weiterverfolgt, oder?
Ich bin eigentlich noch relativ lange drin geblieben, bzw. mehr oder weniger am Rande mitgeschlittert. Montagstreff, ja, wie gesagt, bis zum HDHT, der Schließung des HDHT, dann irgendwann rübergewandert ins FPZ. Ich war auch eine ganze Zeit beim Chaos Computer Club Berlin dabei, bis dann irgendwann das Café geschlossen wurde und dann irgendwo Treffen auf Wiese.
So die Anfänge halt.
Die Szene kenne ich also noch einigermaßen. Ich habe auch damals irgendwie, was war das da?
Dieses Bürgerhaus.
Also dann irgendwann ist es eingeschlafen, weil ich auch keine Zeit mehr hatte, Studium etc.
Sag mal, es wird jetzt hier so ein Veterantreff.
Weil wir ja noch ein paar nehmen.
Ich muss herausnehmen, dass das nur diese 14- und 15-Jährigen sind, die sowas machen.
Ach so, deswegen.
Ja warum nicht?
Ich bin doppelt so alt.
Sicher bin ich jetzt nicht mehr so drin in dieser Szene. Ein bisschen den Kontakt verloren. Was auch ein bisschen damit zu tun hat, dass die ganze Mirbox Szene, die im Prinzip damals bestand, mehr oder weniger weggebrochen ist. Ich sag mal so, Stichwort schwarzer Mittwoch. Der wurde noch nicht angesprochen, das sollte man doch mal festhalten. Ich weiß nicht, ob jemand da ist, in einem Studio, der genau berichten kann, was damals war.
Es gab einfach nur mehrere Hausbesuche mit schweren Folgen.
So kann man es haben, das Ausdrücken.
Du hast gerade gesagt, die Mailbox Szene, die gibt es nicht mehr in der Form und so. Benutzst du das Internet? Ich benutze es aber nicht dafür. Okay, aber hast du nicht? Gut, dann weißt du das vielleicht nicht so. Aber ich habe ein bisschen Eindruck, dass das alles wieder zurückgeht zu abgeschlosseneren Systemen. Nachdem die ganzen Anbieter von kommerziellen Netzen, Compuserve, AOL und so jetzt ja alle aufs Internet gegangen sind und gemerkt haben, es geht nicht ohne, habe ich den Eindruck, dass so ein kleiner Kreis von Leuten sich jetzt wieder beginnt abzuschließen und sozusagen das Internet benutzt, um wieder kleine geschlossene, wie Mailboxen übers Internet zu gründen, um halt wieder dahin zurückzukommen.
Es werden ja immer Nischen gesucht sozusagen, wo man relativ ungestört ist. Und bisher war es eben nach der Mailbox-Szene das Internet, weil das relativ wenig Leute gemacht haben und es ist inzwischen derartig publik geworden und populär, dass das jetzt eben wieder dazu führt, dass sich einige Leute da abschotten. Und unheimlich, wie man auf die Füße treten soll. Aber es gibt inzwischen auch schon wieder Amigas, die am Internet hängen mit alten BBS-Programmen wie AmiExpress, die man dann antennieren kann und sich Wares ziehen kann.
Ja sicherlich, das wird es auch immer weiter geben. Und ich sage mal, schneller ist das Internet auf keinen Fall. Deswegen gab es ja auch bis vor kurzem, also zumindest nach meinen Kenntnissen gab es immer noch Boxen, die bestimmt auch immer noch genauso schnell waren wie zu guten alten Zeiten, sage ich jetzt mal in Anführungszeichen. Nur die Staatsanwaltschaft schläft eben nicht. Und lange her, dass die das Ketten abgelocht wurden, bei LK und BK und sonst wo. Die haben mittlerweile ein recht schlagkräftige Truppe leider.
Ja, schön für deinen Anruf.
Na dann schick's Spaß, verdammt.
Wollt ihr noch telefonieren oder wollt ihr über Sounds reden? Erst mal ein Sound spielen, oder?